take time to be friendly it is the road
to happiness take time to laugh it is
the music of the Soul take time to give
it is too short a day to be selfish take
time to work it is the price of success
take time to do charity it is the key to
Heaven thank
you members officers welcome this is a
council's virtual meeting and everyone
is asked to adhere to the etiquette of
virtual meetings as published on the
council's
website just for some housekeeping now
you will have been provided with the
council's etiquette for virtual meetings
in advance of this meeting however to
reiterate the main points please ensure
your device is fully charged or is
charging please mute microphones when
not speaking please indicate in the chat
bar if you wish to speak and please only
use the chat bar to indicate your wish
to speak it's a bit like when we're in
the council chamber in person you would
raise your hand to indicate a wish chat
should not be used for anything
other when invited to address the
committee please ensure your microphone
is switched on and switch off
immediately once you have finished
please ensure you have switched off or
too silent any other devices you have
that may interrupt the
proceedings if any member encounters it
problems causing them to drop out of the
virtual meeting they should use their
best Endeavors to rejoin as quickly as
possible should the member be unable to
rejoin the meeting they will be deemed
to have left the meeting at that point
and the meeting will
continue numbers to call should you
experience any it problems are the it
help desk on 01789
2620 or Caroline Nash Democrat itic
services manager on
07976 416
353 please note that the meeting is
being broadcast live and that members of
the public are able to view the
proceedings following my recent decision
published on the 14th of October 2020
members of the public May attend a
council meeting to ask a question
subject to compliance with the remainder
of the council procedural rule 10 we
have two questions today under item six
I now call upon the head of the paid
service to report and take a roll call
of attendance and note apologies for
absence of this meeting councilors by
confirming you are present you are also
confirming that you can hear and see
proceedings I will start I can see and I
can hear others thank you David thank
you chairman um yes as chairman said if
you please repeat your name and then
confirm that you can hear and see the
meeting when I call your name please uh
Vice chairman councelor fitter
hello councilor F I can see and hear the
meeting thank you councelor Lewis
Adam Council Lewis Adam here I can
confirm I can see and hear the thank you
councel Victoria
OK hello good afternoon um councelor
Victoria orar I can see and hear the
meeting thank you councel Jay
Barker councelor Barker I can see and
hear the meeting thank you councelor
Tony gomage
[Applause]
could you confirm that you can hear and
see the meeting
please Tony I think you might be on
mute yeah don't worry computer lagged
there sorry about that yes I can confirm
I can hear and see the meeting thank you
councelor
Carill councelor Cargill I confirm I
consider proceedings thank you uh
councel
cleave councelor cleave I can see and
hear the
proceedings thank you councelor
Crump councelor Crump I can confirm I
can hear and see the proceedings thank
you thank you I've been advised
councelor Curtis may be late but I'll
try anyway councelor David
Curtis okay we will come back today with
it later councelor
Eden councelor Eden I can see and hear
proceedings thank you thank you
councelor
Fielding coun John Field
in I know you're there John are you are
you on
mute back on me thank you
uh councelor fi can confirm you can hear
and see the
meeting
mute I unmuted you're unmuted councelor
guest can you hear me now yes I can hear
you thank you thank you I can hear and
see the meeting thank you uh councelor
Fleming uh councelor flaming I can
confirm I can see and hear the meeting
thank you thank you councelor
foik councilor foik yeah confirm I can
see and hear everything thank you thank
you councelor
Foreman councelor Foreman I confirm my
can hear and see the
meeting
C I confirm and I I I can hear and see
the
meeting thank you councilors can I
remind you if you're not speaking can
you please mute your microphone please
uh councelor Jenny fragile councelor
Jenny fragile I confirm I can see and
hear the
meeting thank you uh councelor Jackie
Harris are you
there
no she didn't okay uh councelor Trevor
Harvey councelor Harvey I can currently
confirm that I can see and hear
proceedings thank you councelor pet
hener
sarapin councelor hencher sarapin I can
see and hear the proceedings thank you
councelor
Jefferson councelor Jefferson I confirm
I can see and hear the proceedings thank
you councelor
Jennings councelor Jennings I can hear
and see all the proed
thank you councelor
juned councelor juned yes I can hear and
see the proceedings thank you we have
apologies from councelor Kendall so
councelor
Kettle uh councelor Kettle I can see and
hear proceedings thank you councel
Mills councelor Mills I can hear hear
and see all proceedings thank you thank
you councel odonnell councelor Donald I
can see and hear all proceedings thank
you councelor parry councelor Parry I
can see and hear all the proceedings
thank you thank you councelor
pton thank you I can see and hear all
the
proceedings councelor Pella councelor
pel I can hear and see the proceedings
thank you councelor Richards councelor
Richards I can see and hear all
proceedings thank you councilor
viley councilor Riley I can see and hear
the proceedings thank you councel rock
councelor rock I can see and hear
proceedings thank you councelor wolf
councelor Rolf I can see and hear all
proceedings thank you councel
shenton councelor shenton I can hear and
see the proceedings thank you and
councelor wly hoggins councel Wy hoggins
I can see and hear all proceedings thank
you thank you all thank you
chairman thank you David moving on to
item three the minutes uh the need to
confirm and sign the minutes of the
council meeting held on the third 13th
of July and the annual meeeting held on
the 16th of September to avoid the
necessity of a roll call for the minutes
it has been agreed that you may indicate
in the chat if you have any objections
or
abstentions if none is received it will
be presumed that you are in agreement
with the accuracy of the minutes first I
require you to show anything in the chat
regarding the council meeting of the
13th of
July
Council Rolph you have a question on the
minutes uh thank you chair um on page
19 um there is a question asked by
councel
Fielding um about um uh the arbor
cultural
uh being consulted on on planning
applications um it says that uh from
Council Jefferson that the matter will
be addressed to officers to respond um
would it be possible to have a copy of
that response please I'm quite
interested in the answer to that
question as well thank
you thank you councelor Ralph obviously
all we're looking at is the accuracy of
the minutes at the present time but I'm
sure that uh a copy can be provided to
you thank
you
so no nothing else indicated in the chat
for the minutes of the 13th of July they
will be signed at a later date as I was
not the chairman at that meeting uh now
the the minutes of the annual meeting on
the 16th of September any questions
regarding accuracy Etc into the chat
please if not I can sign those uh
minutes
today thank you everybody nothing
showing there so I will sign those at
the end of today's meeting apologies to
members I did miss out a disclosure of
Interest item two and I now invite
members and officers to make their
Declarations of interest of the meeting
members are asked to note that the
monitoring officer is granting a general
dispensation to all counselors in
relation to item eight on the basis that
without it the number of members
prohibited from participating would be
so great if proportion of the council as
to impede the transaction of the
business uh can I therefore invite
members to declare any other
interests in the chat
please
I see nobody indicating any uh request
Council Council there is yes there is
yes beg pardon councelor fter 1411 yes
so councilor fter declaring an interest
uh call on Council if please yes at the
last overview in scru committee I
declared an interest on R 4 the S
allocation plan to be consistent I've
been advised to do so again today by the
monitoring officer and I will be
abstaining on item 10
should it move to consultation I'll be
helping the community with any
representations thank you councelor uh
councelor rol you've also indicated an
interest uh yes I think along with many
of the other councilors we've all
received um emails ongoing emails from
residents about the meon veil
woodlands so do we all need to declare
that interest I'm sure we've all
received some
emails
uh councilor rol quite right we all have
all all received uh details there I
personally think it would have be a case
for if we were sitting on a planning
meeting rather than a council looking at
the accuracy of these minutes um beg a
pardon sorry about that
uh I'll take it that
uh
we'll regard that as a as a blanket
notification we've all received emails
Etc in respect of the sap and particular
me on
Vil could I also follow up on the the sa
please if you don't mind yes indeed
councel junor could the uh could the uh
members of the
council uh be given advice as to whether
or not they would have other interests
if for example uh they are in um in in
professions that might be for example
selling houses on the on the on the
estate or or any other similar uh
matter thank you counselor I would ask
Phil Grafton if he would like to respond
to that particular question thank you
Phil yes thank you chairman that's a
very difficult question to answer
uh I would I would really need to know
the detail about those particular
circumstances for individual members and
then I'd be able to offer some advice um
as a matter of General principle uh
things like selling houses on the site
if it's known at some Future Point could
certainly raise a need to declare an
interest and possibly to take action in
regard to that interest but as I say
without actually having any detail in
that it's really difficult to apply any
sort of General
principle thank you
Phil I see that uh councelor Pella has
uh indicated that she will be speaking
in support of residents I don't think
that is necessarily a declaration of of
Interest as such
and counselor
odonnell has met with residents via Zoom
with more members of portfolio holders
Etc again I think it's a situation
whereby we have been approached by
members by email some have spoken with
residents the general uh acceptance that
we've all got or received
uh comments from the public Etc will
regard that as a as a general um
Declaration of interest but equally well
it's not a personal interest and it's
not a an important interest not one of
you uh councilor Paris you've indicated
to wish to
speak thank you chairman I just wanted
to advise I do work part-time for an
estate agency in Kon we have just sold a
property in meon Vil but we as a general
rule meon Vil isn't usually part of our
territory because we're based in Kon um
and I have no interest with any
potential developers to Sell New Homes
because that's not as sociality but I
just wanted to declare that in case that
question might have been directed at
myself just for clarity thank you chair
thank you councelor Perry uh councelor
pel you indicated a wish to speak yes so
I don't know whether that's a
declaration of interest but as the world
member I'm 100% behind my residents and
I support their
campaign I think we can leave that for
the uh for the item when it comes up
Council
I was muted sorry I see that councelor
well hoggins has also had a guided tour
I believe other counselors May indeed
also have had a walk around the site
again I think that's simply Council has
taken an interest in it and is not
declaring an interest as
such
uh Phil Grafton you wish to speak up yes
yeah um just just to point out that the
the general thrust of the councelor code
of conduct is about personal interests
in other words things that are personal
to them that might interfere with their
General responsibility to to speak and
make decisions in the public interest of
looking at the chat that I've seen it
it's not really about personal interests
they're just matters that have have come
to their attention or or they they're
supporting their public interest in
terms of their
communities thank you Phil I think
there's possibly some conflict between
this issue here and uh planning meetings
when we are representing people at
planning meetings Etc and declarations
then that can often be a conflict or a
Mis misunderstanding as to what is
required okay uh unless there's any
other Declarations of Interest as such
we shall move
on right thank you members
Right Moving on now to item four and uh
Chairman's announcements um what I would
say is that since my uh 15 years ago
life is much quieter during the coid I
wish we didn't have the co and I was
busy uh but essentially I've got no
announcements to make I've only got the
one Civic engagement lined up and that's
the church service this coming Sunday
and that one is going ahead it's a large
Church in lemington uh but other than
that I've got no other announcements
myself and I shall now invite uh the
leader of the council councel Jefferson
to see if he's got any announcements to
make as the leader thank you thank you
chair um I'll keep this very brief I've
had three meetings with Nadim zahari MP
and one meeting with Andy Street Mayor
of the West Midlands combined Authority
all those meetings were either virtual
or by
telephone thank you councelor Jefferson
I now invite David Buckland as the uh
chief executive to make any
announcements from the council thank
you thank you chairman and I I'll I'll
be brief as well um just just to notify
Council that last week following the
short notice that received the closure
of the a425 for nine months um later
this month we I was involved in three
meetings with colleagues from colleagues
and counselors from both County Council
V District Council and local MP we've
written to hs2 invited them to a meeting
on Friday and presented them with 10 uh
specific questions as soon as we've
received responses back those questions
I'll of course let C know what they're
prepared to do in any way of mitigating
against that road closure um but also
just to let Council know as as per my
updates to to counselors um we have had
an increasing the number of coid cases
within the district we still remain in
the medium tier which is tier one um
we've now had two meetings of the
incident management team meeting which
is a for the whole of the south of the
county that has involves ourselves and
White County white District Council
along with colleagues from the County
Council and public health uh we have
another session scheduled for Friday and
once more I'll update you all after that
meeting with any issues or decisions
that we might need to take as a council
thank you
chairman thank you
David now moving on to a rather sadder
part of our agenda membership of the
council former councelor Bob Stevens
brief reference was made at the annual
meeting to this I indeed I refer to the
death of councilor Bob Stevens former
leader of the council and District
Council of the Souther Ward from 1992 to
1996 and the long itchington Ward from
1999 to
2011 councelor Stevens also served as a
warshire county councelor for the soum
division from 1997 to 2005 and the Feld
in division from 2005 continuously until
his sthp
passing I remember Bob he was the the
second leader uh when I was uh on the
council previously he followed Bill
McCartney and and Bob I would regard as
a true gentleman his style of leadership
was that to to set the example for the
rest of us to
follow uh a great uh a good leader kind
person a real gent and I now open it up
to other counselors to make their
comments and they are
invited
I call upon uh councelor Crump first uh
to speak and I noticed that councelor
Curtis has arrived so welcome
David thank you um Mr chairman hopefully
you can all hear me yeah it's my great
pleasure to speak about the light great
counselor Bob Stevens yeah to use the
cricket into terminology I'm more than
happy to open the batting here and I'll
just wish to pay tribute to Bob as coun
Dixon said ex leader of stford District
counselor a great counselor a true
champion for his residence and uh
everybody who I speak to would say Bob
was a true gentleman whenever Bob spoke
and he didn't speak all the time he was
worth listening to he didn't say in a
demonstrative Mana but what he said had
a lot of weight behind it and made very
imitable sense so a great chat just a
few funny
stories um when I used to play cricket
with Bob I was his equivalent of his
Cricket in spaniel um as you know Bob
was Oly built for Comfort rather than
speed and I used to fill in that point
and Bob was in the Gully and if the ball
went anywhere near me you know is 90%
closer to him than at me it was me that
went for it so he taught me that uh and
the other thing as well was when we were
B him we only used to run ones uh we
never used to run any threes the
occasional two but we used to deal in
ones or fours mainly and he also
introduced me to the fact that we could
have
GMT and British summertime all in the
same day and you just wondered how that
happened well during the summit was
obviously British Sumer time um but then
after the game he went to the Green Man
probably long inter I'm sure some of you
know it and uh for some reason last
orders uh was GMT Green Man time and
last orders lasted a long time so
whether they put the clocks back to make
sure that that last orders lasted a long
time I I don't know but uh that was
another interesting story um and for
some reason if you ever wanted to meet
Bob to have a chat or get some advice
and it was well worth going um we use it
to meet at the blue lies Pub as well so
um again I think that the occasional
glass of lemonade in a local pub used to
smooth the Waters of the long itchington
sou area so great man true gentleman
will be solely missed uh and I I I miss
him Rich every day because I'm I'm
covering his Ward and whenever I speak
to his local councils at coun Paris
councils they they were all um un Ed in
the fact um he was just a great servant
uh to local people rest in peace bar
been a pleasure to have met you thanks
point Thank You councelor Crump uh well
opened councelor
Kettle well continue the criting
cricketing analy coming at number two
batting opposite um Council crumps a bit
scary really but I'll I'll do me best no
doubt it'll be fours or twos in his his
terminology
um councelor Stevens um was an example
to U many of us who knew him as to how
to Be an Effective um and compassionate
counselor um the word gentleman's been
referred a number of times and I would
absolutely support that but I'd also say
he was
wise you needed not to say much to Bob
before he'd got the gist of what you
were saying was challenge for me um but
he he picked it up very
quickly um and then would find work out
a way to try and solve the problem um or
address how it can be raised by other
authorities um canvasing for Bob was
always a pleasure because everybody was
delighted to hear he was standing again
everybody was delighted to know that he
was still interested in their Ward um um
Everybody the other people who was
slightly less delighted was that they
saw the canvas are on the doorstep not
Bob himself but they understood that he
got a team supporting him and anybody
who supported Bob was was welcome on the
doorstep so I don't know what we'll do
with that Bob really Andy is stepping in
very kindly as his as his um temporary
successor and thank you to Andy for that
but um we will all Miss Bob and I know
many many people over many many years
have have commended him on being just
what a counselor should be uh so Andy
said earlier on rest in peace Bob you
will be sorely missed in our
patch thank you thank you
councel I now call on councelor rock and
it's good to see you today councelor
Rock uh thank you very much chairman um
i' I've known Bob I worked out for 24
years is and um councelor Kettle just
reflected on the fact he was wise
because uh the first time I met Bob it
was I was a member of the public
complaining about a highways issue and
Bob was wise enough to um to sidestep it
and said suggest I might want to talk to
the the head of the highways department
and he would take take me to meet him so
he could say I was a troublemaker
straight away but um just laterally uh
2third of my award was shared with Bob
uh as uh a county counselor and uh this
expression uh a true
gentleman I had the the unenviable job
of going around and telling all my
parishes about um Bob's demise and that
phrase just cropped up in response all
the time that he was a true gentleman
and um uh although we sat on opposite
size of the council chamber and those of
us and I sat directly opposite him we
all those of that have been in the
council chamber will know the whispering
Gallery effect of the uh of the Dome
inside the council chamber and sometimes
we we may have heard words from Bob that
we didn't normally hear at Parish
Council meetings in my ward we got on
very very well and he was a great
Champion for the east of the district um
and um we're all grateful for that so
well done Bob you've done a great job
for the communities over here thank
you thank you councelor
uh councelor
Adam thank you chairman um I will keep
it very brief because I can't really
improve on the sentiments already
expressed um by people who knew him much
better than I uh but I knew him as both
a parish counselor and a District
counselor and always appreciated his
input with the greatest respect um and
found his words were often very guiding
in uh supporting the local communities
that he
represented uh he will be and he is
incredibly missed um and and I don't
think we we'll find another counselor
quite like him uh in this part of the
district um and uh yeah I'm tip my cap
to
him thank you councel Adam and uh
finally Council bromich has indicated to
speak as well thank you yeah certainly
growing up Bob was always that taring
influence of a counselor in s that was
always there he was a such a help to the
community as I'm sure councelor Trump
will remember and still applies now that
certainly where I grew up on the old
Council states of Southern which was one
of the poorest areas in the district and
that he tried very hard to improve a lot
he helped with lots of housing issues he
done so much for the community later on
in his capacity as County Council he
certainly helped my older brother when
it come to getting de FIB set set up
around the area and I don't think we can
stress too much how big of an influence
he was and how important he was in this
area as a counselor and as a person in
general that and I think if we could all
just raise a glass to Bob I think that
would be the fitting tribute for
him thank you councelor bromich that's
something I can do this
evening uh no further comments from
councelors I therefore move the
following that the council notes with
regret the death of former counsel Bob
Stevens and extends its sympathy to his
family and friends in their
loss moving on now to public
participation item six of the agenda
there are two questions received from a
member of the public M Rosemary kid and
hopefully Rosemary is ding in to ask her
questions uh have we got her on the line
please yes chairman she's just dialed in
Rosemary it's star six to unmute
yourself are you there
Rosemary
I'll mention to members that the
questions will be displayed on the
website at the same time as Rosemary
asks
[Music]
them yes I've done
that am I
still yes I'm
here good afternoon m m kid uh are you
able to read your question
please
Miss
kid Ro M kid are you are you still on
the line
please
we will to unmute yourself M
kid right am I on now yes yes I'm on the
line thank you Miss if you'd like if
you'd like to read your question please
okay my question is to councelor pton
and I'm I'm making this on behalf of the
friends of me on Vale Woodland
walk I've done
that have we not am I not through yet
please please proceed Miss kid
okay right shall I
start yes please okay this a question is
for councelor
pton and I'm putting this on behalf of
the friends of me Andale Woodland
walk
firstly as the former longm Camp which
includes the native species Oak Woodland
at meon
Vale and the adjacent
stream is identified as a deferred local
Wildlife
site in view of the priority
species in the
area why was the phase two habitat
survey of the Woodland put on a reserve
list for assessment this year are not
undertaken as a priority in view of the
proposal to allocate the Woodland for
300 houses in the site allocations
plan check um would you like me to
respond councilor pton if you'd like to
respond to that one we do have a second
question from Miss kid in Du call than
thank you very much chair um thank you
very much your question Rosemary
wildlife and ecology surveys are the
remit of warshire County
Council I do not know why they have not
progressed with a phase two survey but
can assure Miss kid and the friends of
me on v um that this will be taken up
between our officers and those of the
County Council um You may wish to take
this up with warer County Council
yourself stford District Council
consulted with warshire County Council
on the Sant appications plan at both the
further focused consultation in February
and March of
2019 which first proposed the
safeguarding of the Quinton rail
Technology Center and the proposed
submission consultation in Autumn of
2019 which identified me on Vil as a
reserve site workshire County council
did not supply a response in this regard
uh and again this is something that um
you may wish to follow up with the
County
Council thank you um as a supplementary
I'd like to make the point that before
allocating or proposing for allocation
any sites for Housing Development it's
incredibly important to be aware of the
correct facts and
assessments now as you're aware the
sustainability appraisal the stroke
strategic environmental assessment fails
to refer to the priority species and it
fails to note that this this site is
green infrastructure or that there is
heavy noisy industry adjacent to the
site could councelor pemon explain what
surveys have been undertaken or what
assessments have been sought or advice
sought from the county ecology service
or other environmental organizations
when assessing the suitability of the
woods for Housing Development and the
potential impact of the proposed Housing
Development on the protected species and
the biodiversity of the woods and nearby
areas and the impact of noise on the
proposed house development as well as
residents of existing housing areas from
the adjoining areas of heavy
industry okay councelor Pon thank you
chair and thank you Rosemary following
on from our response to your first
question um plan preparation is an
iterative process through consultation
we engage with stakeholders to identify
and seek to resolve
issues however we are reliant upon those
stakeholders to actually respond to us
having said that I want to make it
abundantly clear that this is a
developers proposal for up to a maximum
of 300 homes if and it's a big if homes
were to be built on this site they would
not cover the entire of the site in
those circumstances the specific wording
of proposal rural 4 which itself May m
be strengthened further arising out of a
public consultation exercise and process
is clear that firstly areas of Green
Space will be retained and provided to
secure habitats for wildlife as well as
for recreational space for
residents secondly the proposal
acknowledges the proximity of the rail
Loop and
struct and employment land which is why
it requires acoustic design measures and
a structural Landscaping buffer to
ensure an acceptable level of RIS
residential
immunity finally I would stress that
this is an early stage of
consultation it is through that process
of consultation that we will work with
the local communities in and around miam
Vale and the Wier District other
stakeholders and elective
representatives to shape acceptable and
sustainable proposals that resolve
issues raised with the landowner and
developer through consultation
if those issues cannot satisfactorily be
resolved then the site just won't be
allocated thank you my second
question um if the council is minded to
allocate the meon veil Woodland for
housing development in the sap and this
is a Preferred Choice that the councilor
is make that the council is making at
the moment so you're saying it's your
best selection process but councilor
pton declared that he is happy to see
thousands of trees cut down and that he
is not concerned about the importance of
the woods to mitigate the climate
emergency all for the health and mental
well-being of thousands of people both
in me and Vale and surrounding
communities who use the Woodland walk
daily Council of pton thank you Rose Mar
so let let us be clear we are only
proposing that the site be put out to
public
consultation public consultation is
important to this Council and it will
shape our View Talk of the loss of
thousands of trees is
premature I supported the Declaration of
a climate emergency and I'm well aware
of the additional health and well-being
benefits of access to open space the
point at tissue which is one that we
must not lose sight of is whether we
consult not decide side but consult on
this
proposal the shest way to protect the
immunity of this site is to subject it
to the rigorous test of a public
consultation
thank I'm just laughing at that thank
you thank you m kid for for those
questions uh hopefully you will be able
to continue to uh to follow the council
meeting uh on your laptop or whatever
you're thank you okay thank you thank
you for the opportunity my
pleasure moving on now to item seven on
the agenda the state of the district and
I invite the leader councelor Jefferson
to introduce this item after councelor
Jefferson has spoken I shall invite
councelor juned and then any other
members who wish to follow her but the
uh report state of the district is for
noting so there won't any votes on this
particular item thank
you thank you chair uh just to remind uh
members that the state of the district
report is to be noted and the issues
raised to considered as part of the
budget making process for
2122 uh draw your attention to para 22
and the statement it's important to note
that the figures included in this report
are from the most relevant data
available and reference the events
happening to the council refer to uh the
DAT to 31st of March 2020 for the most
part however we have included as part of
this stateof the district report the
latest uh information on what's
Happening as a result of the coid
crisis what I would say is that there is
absolutely no doubt that since March
2019 19 the world has
changed I'm going to go through and just
draw your attention to a few points one
of which is the graph on page 50 where
you see the annual population change and
you'll notice that over the last three
years the population of the district has
gone up quite
markedly I'm not going going into the
demographics because basically the
demographics don't change much from year
to year and we still have uh
an elderly
population what I would say though is
that where you get to the population
projections on uh page 54
322 what this actually shows indicates
is that the population of Stratford on
aen district is projected to increase by
14% uh through to
2028 that's an extra
17,8 10 people that's a lot it will put
far more strain on the district
population by the by
20128 is estimated to be approximately
148,000 what is interesting about this
is it's got quite significant
implications for the unitary debate if
one actually looks at those projections
through to
2028 and you actually add in wari
District Council
I would say it is pretty much certain
that the threshold of
300,000 which seem to arrive from nwar
will be achieved by
2025 I'd also expect the census in next
year to demonstrate that our population
estimates are ever so slightly
underestimated at the
moment so if we move
on
uh the ratio of house prices to earnings
much the same as last year we had a
district with very high house
prices and they are for many of the
people in the district
unaffordable which is a real problem and
unfortunately I can't see that changing
soon if we go on to employment by
industry page 61
65 Manufacturing accounts for the
largest number of jobs in the district
13,000 uh which is quite interesting for
our district but most of that is down to
Jaguar Land Rover and Aston Martin at
Gaden uh second highest industry is
wholesale and Retail that's a particular
significance given the impact of coid 19
as is
tourism uh nearly 9,000 tourism related
jobs in the district and it is very
obvious from what's happening with coid
19 that they are taking a big
hit uh if I move on now to coid 19
pandemic there is absolutely no doubt
about it it's had a big hit on our
district uh there's no sign of it ending
and indeed the latest projections
indicate that the economy is going to
take a bigger hit as the coid 19 extends
further and
further if we actually look at the gross
value added then Stratford on aen
District estimated have the greatest
decline in gva of all local authorities
in the West Midlands that is really
important it demonstrates just how big a
hit we've
taken um interestingly enough there are
some implications for wari County
Council if you look at the table on page
66 that out of the top four hardest hit
districts we had Stratford on aen
Tamworth North warshire and rugby three
of those in
warshire so we are really taking a big
hit not only as a district but as a
county it also mentions creative in in
10 to three creative Industries have
been heavily impacted yes we know that
so has
tourism if we move on the impact on key
businesses and organizations in the
district we're all extremely well aware
that the
RSC uh is pretty much closed until
spring
21 uh employment contracts have been
terminated and 90% of stuff fured birth
place trust open the birthplace itself
on the 1st of August but the other
properties are shut and they are
estimating a big hit to their
income and I think this is one of the
things that's really
important it's it the level of support
that Stratford district has actually
had um and if I just look at the
constituency alone because that's the
figures I've got uh for Corona virus
business impact loan scheme there were
194 loans offered to our district a
total of 34.4
million uh business bounceback loans
there were
2,43 loans offered a total of 72.9
million uh in looking at warrier the
number of Lo loans and the amount of
loans we got was the highest of any
District or
burough when you add those numbers to
the 30 odd million that was distributed
by The District Council there's been
something like 140 million pumped into
our district that is not counting the
amount of money that people received for
being fured or for the self-employed
Income Support scheme
the one thing I would say is that loans
have to be
repaid and the two main concerns of
businesses at the moment that I hear
from the Le are one is Cash which links
directly to loans and the other is
redundancies uh the lap growth Hub are
expecting a surg in unemployment
starting with the October numbers and I
think that is one thing that is really
important to realize that at the moment
the numbers really are lagging so we
have not seen the actual recording
numbers in unemployed coming through yet
I expect unemployment to get far
harder and if we actually look at the
council plan approved the meeting of
Council in October
2019 which I have to say was probably
not the best timing given what's
happened and the world really has
changed I think the landscape is totally
different I think for us as a council
we're going to have to recognize we're
going to have less money probably much
less we're going to have fewer
resources and we going to have less
bandwidth to do things in other words
we're going to be able to do
less prioritization will need to be
pretty ruthless and I think all
counselors
need to grasp how much the world has
actually
changed and we are going to need to
reset our own
expectations and through responsible
Community leadership I think we're going
to have to help reset the expectations
of
others there is absolutely no doubt in
my mind that if we actually look the
state of the district what it was like
at the end of
2019 sorry the year
201920 was one thing what it is going to
be like at the end of the year 2021 is
going to be something totally different
and I think we need to recognize just
how substantial the changes are so I am
sorry if that was not good news but I
think that is extremely realistic thank
you
chair thank you uh councelor Jefferson I
now invite councelor juned the leader of
the
opposition uh yes chairman thank you uh
the so we seem to have got an echo on
the line and I'm not sure why but anyway
I'll
continue yeah they uh the leader has uh
emphasized how much coid 19 has Reed
havoc on the economy of the district and
we can all agree on that but the data
here shows that serious problems were
already developing or in place well
before this pandemic this pandemic has
EXA exacerbated inequalities across the
Spectrum we know that we've got an older
population fewer children or fewer
working age adults and in the West
Midlands and in the England in England
higher median house prices they have
risen steeply in the past and there's
fewer genuinely affordable homes that
that are needed not a healthy position
for the future but it's not a a position
that has changed much and it could have
been addressed in the past as well as
needing to be addressed in the
future now since the pandemic as uh the
leader has said we've seen a significant
rise in unemployment benefit and
Universal Credit claims and we do need
to make case the case to government uh
as is already being done uh for help
here but we have to say say that the
health inequalities that mirror those
lower income Figures were again already
in existence life satisfaction has been
on a downward trajectory in this
District since
2016 now a number of areas in the
district have areas on multiple multiple
deprivation and my dis W is one of those
barriers to housing and environmental
deprivation are notable and these areas
for concern have and will become worse
post coid 19 and will affect
disproportionately the lowest paid and
those in
self-employment now much attention is
paid in the document to the internal
vision of the council but are we
actually delivering what residents want
given that only 34% of residents felt
that they could influence the decisions
affecting their local area I feel that
there has to be some change are we
paying due attention to all areas across
the district are we being ambitious
enough despite the financial problems
now we've heard about tourism key driver
of economic grow grow yes uh one of the
there are also other economic growth
sectors including manufacturing but even
before Co 19 it was facing significant
challenges competition and changes in
tourism
patterns uh the leader will probably be
aware of the uh grimsy reviews that came
before the coid 19 and there was there
has been another uh review of the of
grimsy since the coid 19 came along and
it makes for Grim reading
the high streets task force has
requested that major rethinking of the
way in which town centers and Retail
economy functions are made now coid 19
has without doubt made us rethink many
things our health our climate change
responses our well-being as well as our
economy and a major report out this week
shows that we can't be complacent about
our healthy life
expectancy the UK bottom of the league
for healthy life expectancy amongst all
European countries with poorer incomes
and poorer access to Green spaces
playing a significant significant part
so it's now a time for a major rethink
of the council's role externally as well
as
internally I am glad to see that the
climate change panel is finally to meet
some 10 months after the original report
was finished in in hindsight it was good
that the SPD was completed but M much of
what we need to address climate change
is also relevant to the co 19
crisis we have to address some of the
inequalities in our district and show
what we can do we have to look at green
Innovation and production capabilities
as well as addressing health and fuel
poverty a report from the Grantham
Research Institute this week highlights
significant economic growth and jobs
that addressing zero carbon can bring we
need to have some ambition in this area
despite the financial problems otherwise
it will be just like uh chasing uh our
tals downhill all the way so let me
start we need a strong but Greener
economy we need green spaces that
everyone can enjoy we need environments
that encourage health and well-paid jobs
for our younger people and decent
affordable homes and finally we we need
a local government system that feeds
into this unitary debate that will con
continue to cope with crisis and be
responsive to our residents be close to
them and give them what they really want
thank
you thank you councelor juned uh three
councelors have indicated a wish to
address the meeting I'll take them in
order
Council thank you chair um with uh
average house prices now at 315,000
which is the sort of highest in the uh I
think in the West Midlands rents at 775
a month second highest in warshire it's
just it's and with an increasing elderly
population in the statford districts
it's clear that clear to me that the
statford district council should be
exploring um real ways to provide more
affordable housing there's still no
appetite to build its own stock of
housing sadly therefore I don't see any
anything changing in the future in
future state of District reports in fact
inequalities um going forward will
probably become
exacerbated um and uh poor poor rewards
um people in uh living in deprivation
will probably get worse with um not
being able to afford decent housing um
another interesting fact is the um
Avenue kton and welcome Wards I'm kind
referring to those because they're in
straford and I represent
kton um it's likely that these Wards are
going to be hardest hit come the next
six months because they they've they're
in the top five population of working
age people in the
district um and it's
likely um the unemployment rates are
going to go up in in the Stratford
District particularly with the
government ending the Furlow scheme um
and it's going to in increase um
unemployment in in those areas um I'm
hoping the leader will want to Lo Lobby
the government um for more generous
unemployment support for local residents
because that's going to be essential
over the next year for these people to
be able to get back on their feet and
unemployment support is it's not
adequate to um to see see people through
and particularly as they've now ended
the fur scheme so it's going to be a
struggle for for many local residents in
in clotton in every in every Ward but
particularly Wards with High um High
areas of working people thank
you thank you councelor f uh councelor
bromich uh you wish to speak to this
item yes
certainly as the leader is well aware I
am probably one of the more cautious
people when it comes to the district
council's
finances and when I look at this report
I actually think we have are still
underestimating the impact of what coid
is actually going to bring to our
district I think councils are going to
have to have a real big dose of
reality which is either we are going to
make unaffordable council tax Rises or
we're going to have to start being
brutal with our service
but that's not to say that in doing that
we can't create an environment to bounce
back from the coid
pandemic what we should be looking at
now as a council is how our future
actually lies as councelor junor
mentioned about focusing on Green
Technology and the green economy yes we
can create the environment but councils
in the end don't create jobs but we can
create the environment for those jobs of
it and it's going to take all of us
sitting down thinking about things
rationally to actually come up with
proper workable Solutions we can all
come up with wish list we can all go up
to central government asking for lots of
money but the bottom line is in the next
five years that money is going to be in
very short
supply and that is something I have been
saying to this Council now for the past
couple of years about the issues that
Central government will cut its funding
to us and that is going to be a
reality when we start speaking about the
unaffordability of housing I know
probably you from very good firsthand
experience how hard that is coming from
Southern we are very expensive on very
low average wages but this now comes
back to where we are looking at 80 or%
of our new builds are being bought from
people outside the district we can't
control that as such
should we go back to Building Council
houses again that would mean we're going
to be putting our Council in some
serious Deb off it we need guidance from
central government and they need to get
real as well about the housing issues
and many you Cil may not have seen it
but about two three years ago there was
actually a report done into housing
needs of this country Stratford District
was actually found not to actually be
requiring more houses
it was actually found to have a suitable
housing stock but badly allocated round
and this is going to come to an issue
where sooner or later as a council we're
going to have to start speaking to the
housing
associations about how they have how how
they allocate the houses I can give a
prime example on my ward where there is
a lady in a four-bedroom house who
wishes to
downgrade but she can't unless it's
under a transfer
which seems absolutely ridiculous and I
think it's things like that we're we're
going to have to get a bit imaginative
bit creative we're going to probably
have to rewrite policies but we are
going to fundamentally have to face the
fact that there isn't going to be the
money there and we are going to have to
find ways of creating new job
opportunities how that works is
something we all need to discuss we all
need to come up with ideas we cannot
rely on central government now we have
to rely on our own brain
power thank you councelor bromich uh
councelor Adam
now thank you chairman um it was just in
relation to uh the the report that we
were provided for this I was dismayed to
see how little agriculture was raised in
this as part of the um a part of the
whole makeup of the district um and and
how this was approached I appreciate is
small compared to some other Industries
but I think it has to be appreciated the
impact that especially the coid pandemic
has had on agriculture and farmers in
particular and their businesses I think
this needs to be highlighted much more
clearly in the future when um
appreciating the state of the district
um the the way in which we can as a
council support these and create
opportunities for these businesses
especially in light of the um failings
that been seen uh from central
government and defra I've consulted with
the nfu on this to uh to try and gather
some more information and
I'd highly welcome some more clarity and
more exposure on this topic um carried
by uh by the council to make sure that
these issues are not sidelined uh when
compared to other
issues thank you councelor Adam I've got
two more councilors wishing to speak on
this item before we note it uh councelor
pemon thank you chairman um I start off
by finding myself in a strange parallel
world where number one I'm agreeing with
councelor brummage and number two I'm
finding somebody who's possibly more
pessimistic than the leader having had
uh almost daily briefings with him about
where all this is going um yes I think
what members need to understand is that
because we have realism does not mean
that we do not have ambition um coming
into this crisis you have one of the
most ambitious administrations in terms
of wanting to make changes for the
better um that we've had for a very long
time um we are acutely aware of the
challenges that face us we are just
trying to um demonstrate that there are
going to be a lot of roadblocks ahead um
councelor Junior um quite rightly talks
about the opportunities afforded by a
Green Revolution um and um laments the
fact that it has taken some while to get
the climate change panel up and running
but to be blunt we've had an emergency
to deal with in front of us and there is
only so much bandwidth but I can give
councelor junid some assurance that
we've now had the expiry of the calling
period for the South warshire plan
that's going to be the the new core
strategy for ourselves and War District
that work is going to kick off in
November and as I have said on a number
of occasions our next core strategy will
have climate change adaptation and
mitigation running through it as the
golden thread so we are cognizant of the
green issue and we are cognizant of
trying to do something about it as far
as housing is concerned um we recognize
I've got a young I've got young children
younger adult children looking to get on
the housing ladder um and recognize the
challenges and we have lobbied
government because government's recent
proposals around housing numbers and the
planning white paper may actually make
it more difficult to um develop uh
deliver affordable homes for rent so
we've pushed back on that because we
recognize that in this district there is
a a significant need for rental homes so
we're pushing back on that really really
strongly councelor Adam mentioned
agriculture the state of the district is
a headlines report councelor Adam I'd
direct you to our Local Economic and
Industrial strategy which has a
significant chunk of it dealing with the
agricultural sector that itself is going
to have to have a fundamental rewrite
because of coid and that piece of work
is going to be underway um and it will
um I can assure you have agriculture as
part of our significant uh economy so
it's it's really easy to say we should
be doing this and we should be doing
that don't take the absence of headlines
to mean that there isn't consideration
of the detail um we recognize that there
were there are challenges going into
coid those challenges and now
exacerbated uh and we're looking to do
things about it um and finally uh as
evidence of that may I point members to
a bid that was made by this District
Council to government turned around in
under three weeks for the new green
Corridor the enhancement of the
recreation ground um that that will be a
hugely enhanced beneficial open space
for the benefit of all of our residents
and visitors to this District um and I
would point to that as uh activity um
and action over
um speeches thank
you thank you councilor pton uh before
asking the uh the leader to to sum up uh
we'll allow uh in councelor shenton oh
beg pardon councelor Jenny fragile to to
speak that will be followed by councelor
shenton and then I'll ask the leader to
sum up please
I think this is going on for a fair
length of time now councelor Jenny
fredley uh thank you chair just just
very briefly we've talked about
long-term consequences and plans which
will be made with Partners to try and
address some of these major issues I
just like to raise a real concern I have
that residents across our district who
who perhaps have been enjoying fairly
good wages and fairly good Lifestyles up
until now who will find themselves out
of work out of a job unable to pay the
high rents and the high mortgages we've
already talked about and they will be
joining in with the rest of the our our
people in need and we've already sort of
seen people um looking for alternative
accommodation because they're just not
going to be able to afford where they
are at the moment and I do think we've
got an immediate problem in looking for
for housing which um I don't think we've
got it at the moment so I'm joining in
with a little bit of the pessimism at
the moment but I hope we're going to be
able to find some solutions thank
you thank you councelor vagy uh I'll Now
call on councelor shenton followed by
councelor
Jefferson thank you chairman um I'd like
to to offer an alternative a few good
news thoughts um was there all always
going to be things that we'd like
improved and certain certainly at this
point in time it's easy to fall into the
Doom and Gloom mode as a picture painted
by some of the last speakers there are
many reasons why people want to live in
our district so we should celebrate some
of the good things about our rather
beautiful District a point that no
amount of data could ever capture we
live in one of the most beautiful areas
in England in the paper we see that the
median age is
48.2 years of age what that doesn't tell
you on on its own is that the good news
is that this has only increased over the
last 10 years by 2.4
years point to remember though it's the
median age or midpoint age not the
average age in terms of density the good
news is that we are similar to areas
such as Daven tree and of all places
scarra not sure that was a good
comparison but there we go again looking
at over towards if we look over towards
wari they have a density of 508 per
square
meter uh sitting at position 215 in that
table whereas we have 133 people per
square meter infinitely more space
within the county we have the lowest
density but the highest area of land
which takes up nearly 50% of
warshire with wari we would have a land
mass which is just under 64% of the
county
from a working population point of view
my ward wouldn't W has the lowest
percentage due to the large Park home
I'd like to think we have the happiest
group of residents from a h housing
point of view I see that the current
rate of building over the last eight
years has been consistently increasing
and we had a record year for the number
of affordable houses that were built
last year indeed over the next few years
it would seem that if the 201819 level
is maintained that it may actually have
a positive impact on the prices of
affordable houses making them more
affordable than they perhaps are now
this might be good news for people
wanting to get onto the property ladder
when we look at crime rates rate overall
is lower than warshire in terms of
prevalent crimes it's lower than
warshire overall the downside of that
obviously there are some wards that have
uh uh poorer violence of sexual crime
figures but
overall crime is down looking at
employment we see that coid 19 obviously
has and will continue to impact upon our
district prior to this our median
age whoops just bear with me one second
I just managed to lose my place in my
notes Here prior to this our median age
uh
um sorry our median wage was higher than
the West Midlands and Great Britain
qualifications we were the fifth highest
qualified Authority within the West
Midlands area and higher than the GB
average life expectancy for both men and
women is higher than the England average
and the council itself has also received
a number of
accolades so
there are positives and I would ask
whether the leader would agree that what
we're go whilst we are going through a
difficult period there is still much to
celebrate in Stratford district and that
we should have belief in our abilities
to emerge from this crisis a stronger
and more resilient District adapting to
a changing economic landscape rebuilding
our economy to match the demands of this
changing world would also agree that we
are the jewel in the crown of the
Midlands and we have the skills the
people and the location that should
ensure that we emerge eventually with a
strong and vibrant economy and remain a
great place to grow up in to work in and
to live in which is one of our stated
objectives thank you very
much counc thank you councelor shenton
obviously this evening your glass will
be half full and not half
empty uh I'll Now call on councelor
Jefferson to to uh to close this part of
the debate um Council shenton made very
brief reference to the crime figures the
one place that my ward appears
unfortunately in this page 59 the
highest rate of burglary of any ward in
the in the district over to you
councelor Jefferson thank you chair uh
I points there are an awful lot of
positives about the district
I think that we do have the capability
to actually bounce back from the current
crisis it may well take some
time uh I also take on board the points
that Council bromage made and I think
there is going to be a real clash
between the reality councilor bromage
talked about and the wish list that some
people have and at the end of the day in
the short to medium term I have
absolutely no doubts reality will win
out we will do whatever we can to
improve the lot of people in the
district but I would remind all
counselors we are only one player in all
this that means we will have to do our
best to influence other players and I
have to say that we are working very
hard on that I would pick up the point
councelor franley made there is
absolutely no doubt about it that this
will hit an awful lot of people hard and
it will hit very hard an awful lot of
people who are not been used to being
hit hard and that unfortunately is going
to be the case and I think it will come
as quite a shock to the district and
it's a shock that we as counselors are
going to have to help people to come to
terms with and
manage I do find it kind of ironic to
talk about building houses when every
time we try to find a site there are an
awful lot of objections we cannot have
it both ways we cannot have an awful lot
of houses and then object to almost
every site that's considered so if I
look at this as a whole we have been hit
very hard by coid 19 we have the
capability and the capacity to bounce
back we as a council will do everything
we can to help that and I would pick up
the point that councelor pton made we
are ambitious we have been driving hard
and we will continue to drive hard but
we actually have to face the reality so
I turn to the recommendation on page 49
the state of the Stratford on aen
district is noted and the issues raised
to considered as part of the budget
making process for
2122 thank you
chair thank you councelor Jefferson uh
the council notes the
report and uh I will also take this
opportunity to welcome councelor Harris
as I noticed through the chat that
councelor Harris has established contact
with ourselves welcome
Jackie moving on to item eight of the
agenda the independent remuneration
panel members allowances review Dr Dean
Hall the chairman of the indep dep
remuneration panel has dialed into the
meeting to answer any questions which
may be
put I now invite councelor Jefferson as
leader of the council to introduce this
item thank you
Tony uh thank you chair uh I will be
fairly brief on this
um the report is produced by the
independent remuneration
panel uh I would say that
uh it's a very good report I think one
of the things that uh in this report
that may not be fully recognized is the
really significant increase in workload
that's hit all of us including
cabinet however having said that I am
aware that this will be a politically
contentious issue so I'm going to make
some proposals which I hope will be
acceptable to
council the first is
that we accept the special
responsibility allowances for the
chairman and two Vice chairs of the new
planning committee because those are
different
roles the second thing I would say is
that we
reject the
indexation we reject the backdating and
implementation
on the
indexation and the third thing I would
propose is that we do no further reviews
until May
2023 when there is a new
Council I think that most of the other
things in the uh recommendations
actually fall out from the things I've
said so I am formally proposing those
things that I've said to council thank
you
chair thank you councilor Jefferson uh I
now call someone to Second the proposals
as put by the leader uh I've seconded in
the
chat apologies I see that Council pton
has sign in the chat if you'd like to
put that uh verbally please councelor
Bon thank thank you chairman uh I
formally confirmed the seconding
counselor Jeff Jefferson's Amendment to
the recommendation uh and reserve my
right to speak at a later point Thank
you thank you councelor pemon uh
[Music]
councelor
juned yes thank you uh chairman um just
to make it quite clear I have already um
rejected my special responsibility
allowance as I did last year uh and the
liberal Democrat group as a whole will
also not be accepting any changes to
their members allowances um so we we
took that decision after looking at the
impacts of co9 as um outlined in the the
state of the district uh but also from
our own personal experiences so there
will be we will not be accepting any any
um changes to our
allowances thank
you thank you councelor junid uh Council
bromich yeah I think any anybody in
current climate that would dare suggest
increasing the allowance for anybody on
this Council probably would need to have
themselves severely looked at we are
going to be very har financial decisions
in the coming months and there is no way
on this planet Earth can we justify
increasing anybody's allowances and I
think we should all rally around and
turn around and start off here in fact I
would go even further I would actually
be scrapping the fixed travel payment as
an example that we are willing to turn
around and make Cuts ourselves because
in the current climate where a lot of us
are doing online meetings do we really
need to be having this fixed travel
payment I know why it was set up in the
first place I understand that but I
think we need to take a dose of realism
that and I think if we are solid as
account if we are solid as csel and set
an example would a good examp examples
we can set today is to actually remove
even if it's just for a 12 month period
that fixed some travel payment because
in all honesty we're not really doing
the traveling like we were 12 months ago
to justify
it uh thank you counc romich uh
councelor Adam has indicated
please thank you very much uh chairman
um I noticed in the report that um the
reviews are meant to be taking place
every four years with annual reviews
having a light touch I'm must say this
doesn't feel like much of a light touch
considering we voted on a very similar
proposal uh matter last year um and it
does feel quite inappropriate
considering the the hard times that are
being experienced by uh many people
across the district and and so in line
with um the those comments made by
councilor junid I I can't really support
any uh increase in renumeration at this
time
thank you councel
Adam anybody else uh indicating to speak
obviously we've got councilor pton to to
wrap
up
[Music]
chairman uh David thank you chairman um
I believe Tony bromage made a proposal
in relation to the recommendation 40
that was in the um IRP before
I didn't there's no seconder for that
proposal to to amend
that just see if there's a second of
that
composure Council rol has indicated a
wish to speak
and uh councilor Trump has said happy to
Second we'll take uh councelor Ral first
as you uh were first in the queue thank
you um thank you I I just want to say
that I will um not be voting for any um
change in any increases in any
renumeration at
all thank
you councilor
Crump can can you hear
me Dixon can you hear me yeah I'm going
to say I think that it's it's eminently
sensible I don't think it's particularly
contentious about
um removing the L some travel allowance
um my manage is is reduced significantly
obviously it's a 140 plus mile R trip to
usual Council meetings at Stratford um
and I'm I'm more than willing to give up
my whatever it is50 £ 150 a year uh to
to do that so I'm saving far more uh by
using by not using the car uh and also
we're also making a contribution to our
carbon footprint by not traveling all
these extra miles as well so I think
it's it's a positive sign on two points
there thank you councelor Crump uh
obviously this the proposal is in
respect of the the travel allowance
which we're now discussing and we'll
keep the uh comments to that one
proposal until we come back to the uh
previous uh report as a whole uh
councelor John Fielding to
speak have you unmuted
John unmuted and then go straight back
onto being muted again I think somebody
member services want to keep me quiet um
the big the awards like mine where
you've got a lot of villages um spread
across um and I I once drove around it
was 35 miles
um the I know it's a small amount but it
is a useful amount when you've got a big
Ward and I do regularly go and see
different
parishes um and check on things so uh
I'd like to keep
it councilor
rock thank you chairman
um uh I have no problem with the uh
suspension of the fixed travel allowance
while we've got the coid emergency I
just thinking about the proposal and
second's comments on it it sounded like
they were inflating the longdistance
travel which is paid on a mileage basis
with the urban semi urbal and Roar
allowances that were fixed to mounts uh
which were done for quite good reasons
particularly for those with large Wards
so
um could we clarify what's being
proposed whether this is a permanent
removal of that scheme which was to
resolve a problem that we had before or
uh whether with talking about suspending
it for the duration of the coid crisis
so we we don't have to go around the
houses again uh because I think uh
councelor Fielding makes a good point
with very large Wards such as his own um
but I think we it sounded like we were
mixing up travel allowances with the
fixed travel allowance which was
designed to address that problem of
going around large Wards for matters
that weren't met by mileage charges so I
wonder if the proposer and second could
clarify what it is they're proposing are
we saying it's it's gone forever or are
we saying it's going to be
suspended I don't know till the end of
the council or or what could we have
that clarified please thank you
councelor rock I'll invite councilor
bromich as the proposer of this
amendment to speak to
that
you yeah what I'm proposing is that for
the next for the from now and and
including the next financial year or up
until the point basically when the coid
pandemic is over and we get back to
normality that we temporarily suspend
this fix some payment as a temporary
measure at the moment because as I said
we're not using the traveling so much
obviously we still do have the marginal
an as Council Rock said if we need to go
to meetings on that part but I think
it's a temporary measure since most
Parish Council meetings are being done
online at the moment and in fact most
activities are I think we should suspend
this fix sum travel payment for the
duration of the coid pandemic until
basically until such a time when we are
directed that the pandemic is over and
we can res resume back to some sort of
normality can I can I speak Mr chairman
to this amendment yes Council Crump yeah
I think how about if we we clarified it
I know we have a have a light touch
every 12 months um and we could then
review it as is um if the pandemic is is
still ongoing which hopefully it won't
be um but as as a stop Gap um it's
reviewed at the latest um within the
next light touch review by uh by by the
professor so um I think that would
clarify it we've got a we've got a fixed
position then um and then we've got a
formal formal process of doing it thank
you councelor Crump I think councelor
Jefferson's initial proposal was that
the light touches would not be uh
happening between now and the next
review with Dr Dean Hall would be at the
next full Council back in 2023 when
we've possibly all been reelect Ed so
right touches were initially proposed to
cease you are correct
chair uh thank you councelor
Jefferson thank
you I didn't hear that sorry so I stand
correct so apologies for misleading that
misleading the council that um again I
suggest that's the case then we review
it um within 12 months
thank you I think uh councelor penny
odonnell is the next in my que uh
councelor O'Donnell thank you chair um
it was just to say as somebody who has
one of the largest geographical Wards I
completely agree with the recommendation
that as we are no longer do traveling we
are currently online doing our meetings
it would seem nonsensical to have a
travel allowance to cover for that and
also are we not all singing from the
same himy sheet about the fact that
we're not looking to take any increase
in renumeration at the current time um
due to the hardship that is across the
district with our many residents and
that actually it's a cross party
agreement on that that's what appears to
be coming
through thank you councelor o Donnell uh
Mr butland I think you woulded to have a
word thank you chairman and and it is in
relation to the time and the duration of
any suspension so when it was initially
proposed by Council of proage second by
Council there was no duration set and we
are now whenever you have to consider
your members allowances you have to do
so upon receipt of a report from the ARP
hearing the debate I do not know and I
can't foresee the end of the the
pandemic at present um that leaves us a
bit of a dilemma as how we we proceed on
this particular point we we could and
chairman it's been the gift of council
to to make a decision on this point we
could suggest that we suspend it for
this Municipal year up until May um 2021
and then it's reinstated from the the
date of the AGM next year um but I think
you would need to make that decision
today rather than otherwise you'd have
to have a further report back from from
an IRP in the future and conscious of
the leader's suggestion that there is no
further I irport until
may23 um of course if the situation
changed maybe we could review the
situation in in in 21 but I I suggest
that if you are effectively rejecting um
or or amending recommendation 40 as
printed on page 98 then you say uh that
the payments are suspended until uh May
21 uh thank you David uh certainly I uh
would certainly fully support the idea
that we have a definite date and that is
the annual meeting next May so it should
be my view would be they are suspended
until that date and after that or at the
annual meeting the decision can be made
to either reintroduce or to continue
such
suspension councilor fo check I think
you're in the in IQ now thank
you thank you chair yeah I just wanted
to sort of um reiterate what councilor
Donald's just said that it seems like
there is cross Party Support um not to
see increases in allowances um that's
something I certainly support and I know
residents in um my ward in clotton are
going to be facing some significant
hardships
already um particularly uh many of those
residents um are in working in the
service sector and in tourism and um
there there's significant increases in
unemployment that particular W as well
so um I wouldn't like to see an increase
in um any allowances for myself um so um
but it seems like I say as councelor
Donald's just said there seems to be um
cross party
support thank you councelor
K I'm just trying to catch up with uh
people wish to speak to the particular
travel Amendment at the present
time Council of romich are want wanting
to speak to this particular item this
this amendment on the Travel yeah so
here is what I am going to suggest the
amendment the amendment I would suggest
is along lines obviously if youve just
discussed Mr chairman that we suspend
the payment of the fixed sum travel
payment P until the end of this Current
financial year and then at that point
it's brought back to a vote for Council
because obviously at that time we might
have changed circumstances with don't
know but at least we get a chance to
vote on
it thank you Council bromich councelor
Crump you initially seconded I think
councilor Brit's Amendment uh are you in
agreement with Council Brit's Amendment
as just stated yes I'm happy with
that is there anybody wishing to speak
to this amendment before we put this
item to the vote
chairman I think the monitoring officer
wants to speak
chairman uh uh Phil Grafton I understand
you may have something to
say yeah thank you chairman so so part
of what I've going to ask has been has
been dealt with because councilor
bromage has now amended his his amend
mment but I suppose the other question
in my mind is whether having heard that
the or the proposer of the original
motion um councelor Jefferson would be
happy to see that as a friendly
Amendment and to absorb that within his
own
proposals more than happy to do that Mr
Grafton okay so I'm that basis more than
happy to second that as well Mr graft so
on that basis chairman we're right back
to the original proposal which has now
been amended and taken into account
council brage's issue so so that makes
it much more straightforward and unless
there's anybody who wants to speak on
that any further or to make any further
Amendment then you can go to the
vote uh thank you Phil I see that uh
there has been a question I think uh
from somebody wanted some clarification
Council Odon was it on fragile councilor
fragile can I just actually ask for
clarification on the two new posts and
whether those new posts actually add uh
anything extra to the payment that would
have been given to the single Post in
the past uh and what increase in costs
that would be thank
you can I answer that
chair y welcome to councelor Jefferson
fine the planning committee restructure
councelor fragile was considered at the
last uh meeting of council and it's
covered in minute
214 thank you councelor
Jefferson uh David you wish to to
clarify something chairman yeah in
response to the specific question as to
whether the proposals for the special
responsibility allowance cost more for
the planning committees than the the
previous Arrangements no they're they're
actually less so the proposals for the
total sras payable for planning
committees and vice chairs is now less
than when we had the two planning
committees thank you thank you David uh
councelor juned has requested to
speak yes it it does seem to be getting
a little bit um murky around the what
we're actually voting for so I just
wanted some
clarification we are I am happy for the
suspension of travel allowances until
next year I think that that I am I do
not want any um increase in the the
allowances for for members including
special responsibility allowance I have
some issues around the uh I know that
the chairman of planning is not itself
not a new role but the two Vice
chairmans are new roles and I'm just
wondering what level are they being set
at because I I do have that in in effect
we could actually be increasing overall
the special responsibility allowances um
with that I just wanted some
clarification on that one
please thank you councelor juned the the
the figures are obviously in the uh
papers the vice chairman under planning
currently
2069 level to be paid from 1420
to126 and I would mention that obviously
the budget doesn't include those numbers
without any increase in the budget
figures so just to be clear then um what
we are voting for is overall no increase
in the budget figures
overall correct with that in mind that
makes it much much clearer that we're
not voting for any increase
overall thank you councelor juned I
think we've now more or less uh
concluded this debate I think the uh
proposal that is before us is no
indexation in respect of any of the
special responsibility allowances no
indexation for the basic allow allance
and the chairman of planning and the two
Vice chairman of planning to have the
figures as stated as recommended by Dr
Dean and the and the panel and that the
travel allowances which are the the lump
sums not the mileage allowances are
suspended until the annual meeting next
year Che CH chairman David you shook
your head yeah I did sorry chairman I
believe the recommendation was until the
end of the financial year um and not the
end of the municipal year I I I think I
I I might proposed the municipal year
but Tony gomage in second coun com said
Financial year right in that case we'll
take it thank you thank you David we'll
clarify that to the end of the financial
year so that will be uh 31st of March
4th of April that day period as
such right
chairman can I just make clear that we
are as far as I can recall we're
suggesting there' be no increase in
members allowances until uh 2023 it is
not just for this year it's for the next
three years
correct the
travel indeed it is the travel allowance
that's suspended until the end of this
financial year with no indexation to
occur until there is a new Council in
2023 correct that's what we're all
voting
on on that
basis I shall ask the chief executive
David if you'd like to do a roll call
please and we'll take the vote thank you
very much okay so members of council if
when I call your name could you please
respond by saying whether you are well
firstly repeat your name and then
whether you're for against or abstaining
for the proposals which have been um put
forward um so chairman of the council
councilor Dixon councelor Dixon for
four uh councelor fitter councelor
fitter for thank you councel
Adam councel Adam four thank you
councelor oock councelor ok four thank
you councelor Parker councelor Barker
four thank you councel bromage councelor
bromage four thank you councelor Carill
councelor Cargill for thank you
councelor
cleave councelor cleave for for thank
you councelor Crump councelor Crump for
thank you councelor Curtis councelor
Curtis for thank you councelor
Eden councelor Eden for thank you
councelor Fielding for councelor
fielding for thank you councelor
Fleming councelor Fleming for thank you
councelor potic councelor fch four thank
you councelor Foreman councelor Foreman
for thank you councelor Ian
fredley councelor Ian fredley for thank
you councelor Jenny fredley councelor
joury fragle for thank you um is
councelor Jackie Harris are you with
us there repeat from councelor Harris
just for me to repeat the the
recommendations so the recommendations
as is being voted for at the moment
Council Harris is that we all indexation
is rejected um otherwise the report
stands so for the um suspension of the
travel mileage lump sums until March
2021 Council Harris you are you with
us okay we come back to councelor Harris
in a second councelor Harvey councelor
Harvey four thank you councelor hener
sarapin councelor hener sarapin four
thank you councelor Jefferson
councelor Jefferson for thank you
councelor Jennings councelor Jennings
for thank you councel
juned councelor juned four thank you uh
councelor
Kettle councelor Kettle for thank you
councelor Mills Council Mills for thank
you Council me councel odonnell
councelor odonnell four thank you
councelor parry councelor Parry for
thank you councelor pton councelor pton
for thank you councelor Pella councelor
Pella four thank you councelor Richards
councelor Richards four thank you
councelor Riley councelor Riley four
thank you councelor
rock councelor rock four thank you
councelor wolf councelor wol four thank
you councelor
shenton councelor shenton four thank you
councelor w hoggins councelor Wally
hoggins for thank you I'll just call out
to councelor Jackie
Harris whilst councelor haris is
indicating in chat she agrees we already
are unanimous so chairman I think that's
unanimous decision of council thank
you thank you
David moving on then to item nine of the
agenda and uh thanks to D Dean Hall for
being available during that last
discussion
I now invite councilor pton as Deputy
leader of the council to introduce item
nine thank you
Darren thank you chairman I bring uh now
uh minute one to5 from the 27th of July
cabinet which is an update to the
statement of community involvement uh
members the statement of community
involvement um uh is govern how we
engage with communities through the
planning process uh arising out of the
pandemic uh we received um um advice on
planning practice and there were changes
to legislation to widen the uh uh uh
strands of uh consultation to allow for
virtual and remote methods which
previously were not afforded to us to
consider um the statement of community
involvement has therefore been updated
to enable the widest possible
consultation during this difficult time
uh and members are asked to uh adopt the
changes to the statement of community
involvement um just to to add some
clarity uh I think it is government's
intention that uh uh at the conclusion
of the pandemic um uh further guidance
will be issued and undoubtedly lessons
will be learned about the added benefits
of wider Community engagement streams
but for now uh I'm merely asking that
Council um accept and adopt the revised
statement of community involvement thank
you thank you Council pton I call for a
second
uh
do
verbal second
it I'm happy to Second
chair you wish to reserve your position
in case of any debate councelor
shenton you were muted at the at the
first part of that chair um no I'm I'm
as as far as I'm concern I'm quite happy
to recommend that it should be
adopted thank you councelor
shenson does anybody wish to speak to
this item if so please indicate in the
chat nothing being indicated thank you
we'll uh take item agenda item nine has
been recommended moved seconded and has
been
[Music]
concluded chairman
the apologies members uh a roll call in
respect of agenda item nine obviously
nobody wish to speak to it but uh
obviously even need to take the vote so
as as chairman councelor Dixon four
thank you uh Vice chairman councelor
fitter Council fter for thank you
councel Adam councel Adam for thank you
councel ok councel orock for thank you
councel Barker councelor Barker for
thank you councel bromich councelor
bromich for thank you councel Carill
Council Cargill for thank you councel
CLE counc counc cleave for thank you
councel Crump councelor Crump for thank
you councel Curtis councelor Curtis four
thank you councelor Eden councelor Eden
four thank you councelor
Fielding counc John
Fielding are you
muted sorry for some reason he keeps
jumping back
into unmute I'm for it thank you councel
Fielding councel Fleming councelor
Fleming for thank you councelor FK
councelor foic for thank you councelor
foran councelor Foreman for you
councelor Ian fredley councelor Ian
fragle four thank you councelor Jenny
fredley councelor Jenny fragle for thank
you councelor Harris
again I'll come back to councelor Harris
at the end um councel Harvey Council
Harvey for thank you councel hener
sarapin councel hener sering for thank
you councelor Jefferson councelor
Jefferson for thank you councelor
Jennings councelor Jennings for thank
you councelor juned councelor juned for
thank you uh councelor
Kettle councelor Kettle for thank you
councel Mills councel Mills for thank
you councel OD Don councelor Donald four
thank you councelor parry councelor
Parry for thank you councelor pton
councelor pton for thank you councel
Pella councelor Pella for councel
Richards councelor Richards for thank
you councel Riley councelor Riley for
thank you councel rock councelor rock
for thank you councelor
shenton councelor shenton for thank you
and councel Wally
hoggins councelor Wally hoggins
for excuse me chair what about me
councelor Ral I wasn't asked excuse me
councelor R councelor Kate
R councelor Ral for thank you I only had
33s so apologies for that um chairman We
There is councelor that was
unanimous har is also four Al they can't
count vote on this so yes that's
unanimous
thank you David Right Moving on now to
item
10 councelor RI could I suggest we take
a five minute break before we hear say
to recharge our gray
matter can I second that one Mr
chairman we've had a request for a f
minute break uh we'll take a five minute
break then and that's long enough to put
the kettle on get a cup of tea and uh
refresh
councelor just a reminder that you still
be heard whil we're on theour
Slide
that
we'll uh resume the the
meeting that's better right now we can
uh now we can see some people uh so item
10 site allocations plan the preferred
options now some members may wish to
declare an interest at this point if you
didn't do so earlier on this
afternoon I now invite count counc pton
as Deputy leader of the council to
introduce this item Council
pton thank you chairman um at the
meeting of cabinet on the 5th of October
uh minute 267 uh was determined and uh
and that is the site allocation plan um
the site allocation plan um is a
development plan document uh to
accompany the adopted core strategy and
made neighborhood development plans in
order that we can ensure the
determination correctly of planning
applications in the district this
version of the plan which is uh proposed
to go out to public consultation uh
replace replaces a previous and proposed
submission document from July
2019 it looks at a number of specific
proposals including um reserving H
Reserve housing sites sites for
self-build and custom build housing uh
as well as identifying built-up area
boundaries um there is a specific uh uh
item under under rural four which
undoubtedly will uh uh form some
discussion further on however um members
uh following discussion with C the
recommendation to councel is that the
sustainability appraisal and strategic
environmental assessment of the site
allocations plan attached at appendix 5
be received as forming part of the site
allocations plan evidence base
recommendation two that the preferred
options version of the site allocations
plan attached at appendix 2 to the
Agenda Report be endorsed for public
consultation and in so doing the
previous proposed submission dated July
2019 version of the site allocations
planned before formally
withdrawn recommendation three is that
the policy manager in consultation with
the deputy leader and portfolio holder
for place be authorized to make any
further minor and editorial amendments
to the site allocations plan prior to
the preferred options
consultation and the final
recommendation recommendation four is
that section 7.13 of appendix 2 be
substituted with the text set out in the
appendices to the update sheet and this
amended version of the site allocations
plan subject to recommendation three be
recommended for public
consultation under recommendation
two thank
you thank you councilor
bton I now call for a seconder please
indicate in the
chat councelor Jennings just beat
councelor Barker to the to the bottom
councelor
Jennings councelor Jennings here confirm
me I second the
motion thank you councelor Jennings I'll
open the debate but uh prior to uh to
that I'll just make this one comment if
there are any amendments proposed during
this item which have not already been
provided in writing to the officers for
putting on our
screens I will call an adjournment so
that we can specifically get the exact
text of any proposed amendments clearly
in front of all members thank you I now
open the
debate the first speak first counselor
to speak is councelor
perella yes thank you chair um I
disagree with recommendation four and in
particular its reference uh to the
current section 713 or the preferred
options of the site allocation plan and
would like to move an amendment to
change it
and once this amendment is seconded I
would like to speak in support of my
Amendment and I've sent the written
Amendment so it should appear on your
screens thank you coun perella we shall
now await the sight of that Amendment so
that we can all take it on board so
there'll be an adjournment while we do
this
second
chair you also need a
second can I read my
Amendment yes uh yes Council pela yes so
um I proposing changes to the
recommendation four of item 10 of the
agenda of this full council meeting in
relation to the preferred option site
allocation plan
2020 that section 7113 meon Vil former
engineer resource Depot Long marstone
proposal of appendix to be changed as
set out below and that this amended
version of the site allocation plan be
recommended to council for public
consultation under recommendation two
changes to se
7113 rural 4 neon Vil former engineer
resource Depot Long Marston to be
changed from a specific site proposal
for Housing Development to a safeguarded
site in view of its importance in terms
of the district's green infrastructure
and connectivity social mental and
physical wellbeing and climate change
mitigation strategy delete all
references under proposal rural fall to
the allocation of the Woodland site
including all its Associated open and
wooded are areas and meon Veil for
Housing Development add a new
safeguarding policy to proposal rural
for which states that the whole of the
Woodland site including all Associated
open and wooded areas will be
safeguarded and enounced as a
multifunctional accessible Green Space
add a new policy to rural to proposal
rural 4 for future management of the
whole Woodland site with reference to
biodiversity screening accessibility and
green connectivity
as an educational resource for the
district and importance of the woods in
mitigating the climate emergency and
further Section 8 part of the site
allocation plan the map or rural for
meon Vil former engineer resource Depot
L Marston to reflect the change policy
showing the whole site including all
Associated wooded areas and Associated
open areas have SAU guarded from built
development thank
you
thank you councelor Pella now that we've
uh heard that Amendment read can we have
a seconder
please councelor
juned um councelor juned yes um I I
thought um that Peter H serim was going
to second but I but in his uh if he
can't do that then I'm
seconding that's all right with me Susan
yeah sorry councelor juned your appear
your name appeared in my my chat and I
didn't see anything from councelor Peter
cin um so on the basis that the
amendment on the basis that the
amendment has been put and seconded we
now
chairman ah right I'm reading uh Council
pton has got a a point of
order chairman this amendment seeks to
introduce a whole raft of new policy uh
changes um I'd like to move for a brief
adjournment to allow for the planning
policy officer who I think it would be
useful for the uh consideration of this
item to be available to uh provide some
technical advice I am aware that he's
available but we do need to get him into
the meeting uh to be able to give uh I I
think it would be useful for members to
have some planning policy manager advice
about significant changes and uh making
up policy on the hoof so I'm I'm moving
for a a a quick adjournment to just to
get him on the on the line if I can get
a seconder for that or if chairman you
can agree to that that would be
helpful I think I that request it seems
a very sensible route an
adjournment
take
yeah
an adjournment for 10 minutes I
think
members Sor sorry for that but uh when
we're faced with these uh very technical
amendments it's only appropriate to get
some officer input to it and I'm going
to invite councelor per Geller to speak
to her Amendment next but I will advise
members that we will then listen to John
careford as our professional advisor in
these matters so councelor
perella thank you chair so um this
amendment uh would allow the rural
proposed four to be included in in the
preferred option site allocation plan
not as allocated to Housing Development
but as a safeguarded and protected site
because of its importance in terms of
green infrastructure and connectivity
physical social and mental well-being
and climate change mitigation to The
District in the same way the other sites
in this plan are
safeguarded for their importance for
example to
employment rural 4 as updated in the
cabinet version is still very weak as he
only seeks to safeguard the mature trees
and non-plantation Woodland there
there's no mention of the importance of
the Woodland to protect his species or
indeed no mention of
biodiversity I would even argue that the
way this policies currently wed will not
give the council much control in any
future proposal put forward by the
developer except for the maximum number
of
houses and I do agree with councelor
pton statement that the shest way to
protect this amenity is to subject this
side to the rigorous test of public
consultation my Amendment will will
allow everyone to have their say from
residents to statutory consules not on
whether this site should be developed as
wasn't in the press release by the
leader but rather on whether this site
should be
protected the site is clearly
safeguarded anyway from Bill development
in the core strategy itself core
strategy policy
a1i proposes to retain and denounce the
Woodland plantations this area is also
as we heard referred um a the third
local Wildlife site and it is subject to
a uh s106 agreement signed in 2012 and I
think is my understanding that this
agreement still stands in relation to
the
Woodland the so the dis agreement
recognize the importance of the
Greenfield area within the larger
Brownfield site the Woodland is the last
wild green space left on the old long
marstone engineer Depot it cannot be
reduced use or fragmented without
permanent damage to its
biodiversity and regarding previous
planning consent since then the council
has declared the climate emergency and
the coid 19 pandemic has shown us the
fundamental human need or or even right
to have access to Greens spaces such as
these further the consent was for all
the logies proposing the part of the
Woodland which includes open grasslands
The Lodges would not have been p
permanent dwellings and therefore they
would not have required the extensive
Road and Associated infrastructure that
300 houses would require indeed phase
five put forward by the lamb Doner
includes an access road for substantial
vehicle movement cutting through the
Green Way interrupting this important
green travel infrastructure for the
district fellow counselor the climate
emergency is accelerating and each one
of us as a du Dy to ensure that the
actions we take today will support local
National and Global efforts to protect
our planet for future
generations and yet here we are today
debating whether the clearing of several
hectares of Woodland the fragmentation
and loss of wildlife habitat and
biodiversity from canopy to floor is
Justified to Make spaces space for
houses and let me tell you that we are
acutely aware of the need of Housing and
especially affordable housing and indeed
my world has welcome its fair share with
the garden village and of course meon
Veil itself but the balance of Housing
and wild green spaces must be protected
most of the Brownfield areas have now
been developed or are in the process of
being developed and the retainment of
the Woodland was an integral part of the
original Vision as a council we should
not just build the houses we should
build
communities the Woodland is immensely
precious to the meon Community to the
surrounding Villages and farther a field
with visitors from straford along the
Green Way not just because of its
ecological value but but also because of
his social value so I ask you today with
this amendment what kind of council we
want to be let's protect and enhance
green areas like these across our
district the meon veil Woods could
provide a catalyst for the council to
implement its own pre-planting program
and announ its green Network to support
this Strate strategic games and to
support the health and wellbeing of the
people we
serve consider the kind of community you
want your children to inherit clean
green and sustainable or poorly planned
degraded and with fewer good quality
places to enjoy in our lifetimes we get
few opportunities to make such a
positive difference and this is a chance
to live a lasting Legacy for our
residents let's send a message of Hope
to the people of the district that this
Council will put nature and well-being
at the heart of its decision and
policies and so I urge you to vote for
this
amendment thank you thank you councilor
Pella I would now ask John kford if he
would like to uh advise the council uh
in a professional capacity thank you
John uh thank you chairman uh good
afternoon counselors um the the specific
point about uh in inserting a new
proposal uh such as safeguarding
proposal green space t nation into the
sap at this point um I'll just focus on
that on that particular point the
technical aspects of that um it it would
require additional work to be done we do
need to uh apply any proposal on a
consistent basis uh there may be a
number of sites elsewhere across the
district that would uh warrant a similar
level of protection um so I think in
order to uh identify those sites um
establish a methodology for the
identification assess them whether they
meet those criteria um I think you are
looking at um a further piece of work
fairly fairly significant piece of work
um which would um would also have to
revise the sustainability appraisal as
well um I think that together uh would
result in a delay to the site locations
plan going out to consultation we're
looking to start that uh on the 29th of
October subd District through Council
this afternoon uh we would not be able
to get it done turned around by then it
could well delay it into the new year um
it is the the knock on consequence of
that delay that uh is a concern um
members you'll be aware that the core
Strat itself will become five years old
next July um that in itself is not an
issue subject to
uh it's an assessment whether it it's
still up to date um now the government
have consulted on increase significantly
increasing the housing numbers the
district if the housing numbers were to
were to increase um the the site um the
course strategy uh I think there would
be question marks about whether it would
be up to date having a s allocations
plan uh that's progressed a long way
down the line line it would enable us to
uh transition into that new higher
figure much easily than without it in
fact we' probably back to Planning by
appeal if we don't have a pool of
Reserve sites we could call upon uh to
um to use uh to increase our housing
Supply so I think there are quite
serious
ramifications of uh delaying the Start
allocations Plan when we come to it in
next July so hopefully that's helpful
chairman thank you
thank you John hopefully you can stay
for the uh for the debate
um we're obviously only going to be
talking to the amendment not the uh the
other proposals at this stage and uh
councilor pton has requested to
speak uh Council of pton wishes to speak
at the end at the end of the discussion
on this amendment so so councelor junid
uh councelor junid if you'd like to
speak to the amendment um this one this
um Amendment refers to a very specific
site and a specific um location uh not
to the whole of the um the the the
district or which other other areas will
be able to put forward changes through
the consultation is should they so wish
now the the nppf makes it clear that we
should be protecting and enhancing
biodiversity uh and the benefits
available from n natural capital and
ecosystems including
Woodland detrimental impacts on
recreational opportunities have to be
considered as well as securing
biodiversity net gain if significant
harm to biodiversity resulting from a
development cannot be avoided or
adequately mitigated then planning
shouldn't be given I really don't think
this just should depend on whether trees
are ancient or veteran as all trees are
valuable for climate change
mitigation to co coincide with World
mental health day the Royal town
planning Institute published practical
advice on mental health and town
planning giving advice on how UK
planners can work within the current UK
planning system to protect well-being
and mental health and it's this is
clearly uh a reason why this should be
protected the upcoming planning reforms
in the white paper were referred to now
that not only risks marginalizing the
voice of communities and local
government they are extremely weak on
reductions in CO2 and plans for climate
adapt
adaptation they signal more development
uh uh and give maximum advantage to the
developer development uh over the
communities and this is one reason why
we want to be able to go forward with
developing a sap but we don't see the
reason for delaying it because of this
amendment the the proposals in the sap
are weak on protection of Green Space
they don't provide sufficient rigor or
provision precision and the consultation
is where this will be strengthened for
other areas as well as um the um the
meon veil during the consultation period
that is when we can strengthen all the
green spaces all the um areas uh and
look at climate change mitigation and
other adaptation measures during the
course strategy uh review I also hope
that not only will we building stronger
biodiversity me measures but that we
will also seek a local green spaces
designation I have not asked for that in
this particular sap consultation because
of the the delay uh that it would give
and I do not want a delay I believe that
this amendment does not delay the whole
whole sap it does not require a great
deal extra work it can be taken just as
the independ the independent this one
Amendment for this one particular site H
and I think that whether there are if
there are other amendments they also can
be judged on those individual sites as
well thank you councelor juned uh
councilor bromich you're next in
MyQ yeah certainly well first of all I
always note the concern of any lot of
biodiversity is especially in an area at
the moment where we're getting uh a
biodiversity rate by hs2 and in the past
where we've given plan where the
council's given planning consent into
the area of restraint in Stow
Valley however when we put these sorts
of amendments through to remove 300 OD
houses that we have to find some other
alternative to put them now going back
to the when we adopted the cor strategy
in 2016 shortly after we'd had an
election myself and councelor Trump
we're surprised to find 550 OD houses
extra in sou because we had a shortfall
we take 300 out of our Reserve sites at
the moment and this site allocation plan
where do they go we need to find
somewhere and find somewhere fast
otherwise this course strategy could be
compromised by next summer the risk then
is we go back to the developer freefor
all pre precour
strategy what seems to be the particular
issue here
is that we probably need to review
overall our planning
policy and work out how we are going to
become more environmentally friendly on
that planning policy whether we start
insisting that we have Woodland areas
attached to new housing developments to
try and increase our overall tree
numbers these are the discussions for
the
future in regards to me on Veil I
remember very well when we were
discussing this core strategy
it was always probably assumed that the
site was going to have extras on on the
site on the reserve
allocations and when we looked for sites
for Reserve allocation I remember being
involved in discussions that I B up the
fundamental issue then of Well's Bor
Airfield for example which I was told
was never going to be available before
2030 but if we take these 300 out that
suddenly puts that Airfield back into a
possible discussion does it put in model
Village on the semx site when they were
providing 2 and a half th000 bear in
mind that government is going to is
threatening to put an additional 3,000
houses into our district so what we have
in Reserve at the moment we may still be
taking a lot more we've got to going to
have to make some harsh decisions but we
can make responsible decisions and we
can look at minimizing impact but the
bottom line is unless we propose an
extra 300 houses from somewhere we we
cannot accept this amendment and if the
PE if the proposal would like to suggest
where these 300 extra go that then tell
me where you're going to put these
houses that because this site allocation
plan we need to have going effective and
going fast otherwise we compromise our
core strategy now I see we're getting I
get reading the comment here in the chat
turning around and saying it's not a
reserve site what we haven't adopted any
reserve s sites yet we have ideas and
this is what's come forward we now need
to make decisions of this the question
is if not me unveil where else and I
think that needs to be put on the table
in this amendment we can have an
amendment trying to secure the
environment I'm sure we in s would love
the Stow Valley to be secured that from
development indeed I've only turned
around and actually been fighting this
for a number of potential developments
for a number of years but we have to be
firm now in this and say we have a
proposal if we are going to remove a set
that proposal we must be able to suggest
the alternative otherwise it has to stay
there thank you councilor bromich uh
councelor F uh you're next in MyQ thank
you chair um yeah I went to the uh Woods
yesterday and
had a had a walk around for about an
hour um and actually when once you're
actually in into the area into the site
itself you you kind of um you kind of
then realize actually this is this is a
whole lot bigger than um talking about
houses developers what goes where what
it it becomes much more emotional than
that much more emotional and um it I
think coid 19 has Chang everything it's
it's a game Cher and when you have these
beautiful walks around a wooded
area and it gives so much joy to so many
people that now live there I mean that
that Woods those woods a few years ago
were an isolated piece of nature with no
W with very few people benefiting from
how wonderful they were but now we're
building all the way around them which
means the community is changing
the area is changing and people are
benefiting from from that beautiful
Woodland so um if it means we have to as
a council work a little bit harder to um
perhaps have some delays to uh to the
plan and work
differently then um the council must be
more Nimble in the changing
circumstances and we have got changing
circumstances and local residents feel
that their Open Spaces I go walking up
in welcome Hills in the kton area almost
on a daily basis and uh it's changed
it's changed and we need to change as a
council and so the decision we make
today is a political choice not a
technical Choice thank
you thank you councelor f uh councelor
Curtis but uh before asking you to speak
councelor Curtis I just mention to
councelor perella that you will be
called at the end of the debate on the
amendment uh so you don't need to come
in during the course of that debate
thank you so councilor Curtis please
thank you chair um and thanks to John
Kord for giving that clarification
earlier um but I think the to me the
fact that other sites haven't been
identified as requiring
protection doesn't constitute a good
reason for not protecting this 35 Acres
a very important Woodland a natural
habitat I think to me it rather
demonstrates a failing in the site
allocations plan
process and I was surprised I admit when
I discovered that that Woodland doesn't
appear to be taken into account When
developing the site allocation plan and
and that's really what I want to say but
just also to reply to to speak to
councelor bromy
I think if we have a choice of an
abandoned Airfield or 35 Acres of
Woodland on which to build houses I
think I know certainly where my
preference would would lie and pick up
councelor fic's points as well coid 19
and climate change are or they actually
should be game
changers the council has said several
times that climate change will involve
us making difficult decisions but thus
far we don't really seem to be
addressing those difficult decisions and
I think to destroy willfully destroy
this Woodland flies absolutely in the
face of the climate change emergency and
I would find it very difficult to see
how as counselors we can look our
residents in the face and say we
sincerely recognize the challenges of
both both coid 19 and climate change
while we still destroy Woodland thank
you thank you councelor Curtis uh
councelor
Kettle thank you Mr
chairman um I've listened carefully and
I was as you might recall chairman when
we passed a climate change motion
some um 12 or more months
ago um and everybody was
unanimous um in supporting the issue
about climate change and how we minimize
its impact in this District so the
council is quite clear on
that where I have a concern is with with
this
amendment
is not that we are reversing that
earlier
decision but
firstly um we are ignoring ing the
advice we've just heard from our senior
policy officer who is um highly
experienced in these matters and if his
opinion is that by rejecting but by
accepting this amendment we have to
bring into account a number of different
issues which might have the same or a
number of different areas in the
district might have the same um for same
category we cannot ignore Mr kord's
advice he is our senior officer in
planning
policy so members be wary of ignoring Mr
careford
secondly this is not a planning
application we are miles from planning
applications this is a consultation
document and I have
read
number I Haven read them all there have
been a very significant number of emails
we've all had people talk about lack of
consultation people talk
about Council overring overruling uh
local feeling all of which I can
completely understand if they were
accurate but this is a proposal to go
out for
consultation we will post consultation
have a revised document that document
will again go at
consultation there will be so many
opportunities to consider but until we
have that consultation and have the
feedback from the
consules then it is
inappropriate I believe to turn around
at this stage and said this site and
this site only must be
excluded we've been in by Council pemon
um in the copy of some of the letters he
sent to some of those writing
in that this will better
protect the woods than the current
position where they are now in where
this is a site within the core
strategy and that is what we're all
trying to achieve better protection but
there are two mechanisms one we throw
this site out and as Mr careford has
clearly explained that is going to have
a major impact on our delivery of this
document and the council the issues that
Council BR Council bromage has brought
up as well which I we we've heard I'm
not going to repeat them um so ladies
and gentlemen members
counselors just remember this is
approving a document for consultation it
is not a planning application which will
D demn this Woodland to
destruction let us see what everybody
says let us pull those response in and
when we have those responses then let us
make a decision across the whole
district and in relation to rural four
whether this is after that consultation
the right way to go forward and if the
decision is it isn't then we'll have to
change it if however all the technical
advice and the popular feeling is it is
the right place then so be it but please
let us take this as what it is a
consultation and nothing more at this
stage thank you Mr
chairman thank you councelor councelor
Carill
please thank you chair I I do support
the public consultation uh of the
reserve sites for a number of reasons
including getting the best outcome for
the sites contained for the residents
but also as an engagement exercise with
the residents as the state and district
report shows only 34% of residents fact
they could influence decisions in their
local area this is a golden
opportunity as a very popular part of
the country there's demand for homes
here in the report again affordable
housing is at the top of presidents
priorities we've known for some time
that the average house price in scrap
for districts above the national average
significantly we now see that the
district's lower quar house prices are
apart from flats and masonet are
onethird higher or act costs about
£80,000
needless to say this translates into
higher rents and given the ratio of
house prices to uh earnings of over 11
to1 we can see the imperative to do more
in the affordable housing market and
sector to reflect for a moment if I may
on the residents the meon Mayon Bale and
the residents they've put forward a very
good campaign uh to retain the trees and
their local woods and why not it's a
beautiful area but many of my
communities and other communities feel
exactly the same I'm fully supportive of
retaining Woodland open spaces and I
have campaigned on that I'm a country
lad at heart and I want to retain as
much as I can of this beautiful
countryside however as residents of meon
Bale they have homes I have members of
my community that cannot afford a home
either for themselves or their children
allowing them to to remain in the
community they were born into to them a
home and a roof over their heads is more
important than some
trees until an alternative funding model
comes along it's obvious we if we want
more affordable housing we have to build
Market homes to pay for them houses have
to go somewhere and much as we would
like it we need to be very aware we
cannot protect all Open Spaces including
Woodland
forever the point raised in one of the
on Bale residents emails I think I got
it today in a of fact mentions building
out long Ms of Brownfield site yes
please but we've been stopped by the by
not having the the the relief Road and
there's opposition to that how come we
win we can't on this one finally we've
been advised that this amendment of the
GRE to protect the green Open Spaces I
can't accept that given the advice and
such that we've heard today
uh public spaces sorry green Open Spaces
is a passion of mine but this is a
myopic look at just one area in the
district I have spaces I want to protect
and no doubt others do too if we're
going to look at this then let's look it
in detail for the whole district and not
just one part of it to accept this
amendment May will to lay the core
strategy and then we enter Planning by
appeal be careful what you wish for
thank you
chairman thank you councelor
carel uh councelor Jefferson and I'll
just mention that at 5:00 we must take a
vote as to whether or not we continue
this uh as we will be in uh session for
three hours at that stage and I'll be
looking to see whether or not we want to
time limit any extension uh the offices
would normally close at 6 o'cl thank
you thank you chair I'll be very brief
having heard uh Mr kord's uh input uh I
think we should reject this amendment I
think the fact is that the sap is going
to consultation the points that can be
made on consultation can actually be
picked up in the final version so I see
absolutely no reason to go ahead with
this amendment and I think when we put
the sap out for consultation then we
should get the feedback then enable us
to deal with residents
concerns thank you councelor Jefferson
councelor Jenny
fredley uh thank you thank you chair
sorry I was a bit slow I'm getting up um
I'm well aware of the horns of the
Dilemma the district finds itself in
between providing sufficient housing
which we've already spoken about earlier
in this debate efficient housing that
people can afford I believe the
government white paper coming forward
actually mitigates against us being able
to provide the affordable houses that we
will need by imposing the numbers of
houses that it uh that I understand it
might be doing however sites in this
area are already s
safeguarded this uh Amendment attempts
to uh highlight safeguarding on a
particular wood in a particular ation
which is about to go for a particular um
uh recommendation which is about to go
forward and I think we do need to think
so carefully about our Precious Places I
was part of this uh uh uh this as part
of this Council when I think we rushed
through in the last cor strategy a
particular line on a map which went
through for consultation and actually
the Southwest relaf road now seems to be
really down the track and we didn't
think that through sufficiently well at
that time I do not want to see the same
thing happening with our precious
Woodlands uh not being sought through
carefully enough and we've already heard
please for these Woods to be to be cut
down and built on we need to make sure
that our safeguarding measures are
robust and enforceable going forward and
I hope that we approve this um um
amendment in order to strengthen the
thinking of our officers to protect
Precious Places in the future thank
you thank you councilor fragile uh two
more speakers on this amendment which we
might just manage to get in by five
o'clock councelor
cleave thank you chair um first of all
may I say uh with global warming our
first priority should always always be
to conserve existing Woodlands whether
they all growth or young regrowing
forests a mature tree can absorb carbon
dioxide at rate 48 pound per year
cutting down these trees alone will
release more CO2 than any new trees can
absorb as Council pan said when we
declared a climate emergency we need to
make the difficult decisions and this is
one of them do we really want to add
more CO2 to our
environment this amendment is not about
removing a site but reassigning it as a
safeguarded site uh so I have a question
uh to John kid of ma can he confirm
whether whether or not these 300 homes
are critical to our site allocation plan
thank
you thank you councel cleave uh
councelor Riley
please thank you
chair
um I am not taken in by um people saying
that this is just um a proposal or just
for consideration um as far as I'm
concerned it's the thin end of the wedge
we're starting down the road and um and
it's something that we should not be
considering we should be
preserving um Woodland there are other
sites in the district which don't have
Woodland on them which would which could
be considered for housing ahead of this
um what was the other thing say uh as a
as a green counselor I can't countenance
cutting down 35 uh Acres of Woodland to
put houses on um and if it delays the
um the the document we talked about well
so be it but I'm not going to S
sacrifice 35 Acres of Woodland for a
document thank you very much
thank you councelor Riley I was going to
leave questions until the end but uh as
people are now introducing these into
the chat I'll ask uh John Kord if he'd
like to address Council Cleaves one
question thank
you uh thank you chairman um yes just to
confirm so the um rule four is not a
proposed as a reserve site it is a
standalone specific site allocation so
it is not critical to the s allocations
plan in that sense um I would just draw
if may members attention to the wording
of the amendment went through cabinet
which is is looking for up to 300 homes
and to preserve uh or retain as much
Woodlands as possible so it's in that
context that we're looking to consult
thank you
chairman thank you John uh I'm now going
to call on Council of pton uh in respect
of the the uh the amendment and then
councelor perala and then we will took
the amendment to the vote uh councelor
pton thank thank you very much
chairman I think what we need to do is
first of all to understand this is not a
planning committee we are not today
making a decision on whether this site
is to be developed or
not we also need to to really focus in
on the
outcome and the outcome that the ward
member and has been expressed expressed
by other members of this council is to
find a way to protecting this site so
you have to ask yourself the question
what's the best way to do
that and where we are going with this is
to consider changing the nature of the
site to call it a safeguarded site um to
add a safeguarding policy and a proposal
for management of the site
none of which have any evidence-based to
support them um none of which
demonstrate in any way shape or form
that this site is so exceptional across
the district that it alone has to be
considered in this way as against any
other um woodland or open space and in
that point John Kord is absolutely right
we would have to go back and look at the
entire District now the site of itself
300 houses John kev's absolutely right
doesn't doesn't hit the uh core strategy
in that sense but but the but the delay
to the sap
does and you know you you know uh
councelor Riley is prepared to pay the
price of an additional 800 thou 800
houses per year for the next 20 years if
we work on the government's numbers um
and that will create huge
difficulties um we also seem to think
that we're acting in isolation
um number one the landowner and
developer can bring forward an
application at any time they
wish they would undoubtedly look to the
decision uh if this amendment were to go
through
and challenge us on the absence of an
Evidence base at the same time um if we
do not allow this site to go to public
consultation we deny the public the
opportunity to have the widest possible
response and consultation and I can see
David Curtis laughing at me absolutely
councelor Curtis if you want to look
your residence and everybody else's
residence in the eye and say you you you
stopped this that's great then look him
in the eye in 12 months time and say why
you didn't stop a planning application
on this site because the issues that
will be brought forward will be narrow
you won't be able to bring these issues
forward that you've raised today you
won't be able to demonstrate there's an
evidencebased to support what you've
done and okay you can only get anywhere
near that through the public
consultation which is focused and Broad
and creates an Evidence base that
ensures that if there is a decision to
take this out it's done in a way that
can be supported and gives absolutely
everybody the best possible chance to
ensure that that decision is robustly
supported by a planning inspector if you
want to take your chances at a planning
in a planning application um I think you
really just need to consider and be
careful what you wish for um public
consultation is important to this
Council okay and our officers listen to
public consultation I listen to public
consultation what I need is the evidence
and what you're doing is tying
everybody's hands behind their back
you're tying residents hands behind
their back in in an ability to challenge
whether this site should be developed at
all um members there is no
way that we are going to be able to
stand up these changes and not be open
to
challenge you are being what you will
end up doing is leaving this to the
vagaries of a planning
application and ultimately um I am
absolutely clear that the best way for
councelor perella councelor Curtis
councelor brommage and uh every other
counselor in this uh in this virtual
room who has concerns about the site the
best way to achieve the outcome is to
reject this amendment vote to get the
thing into the public consultation and
counselor Curtis and counselor perella
you can make your case and the residents
the friends of me onve would have an
opportunity to actually bring an
evidence-base to support their arguments
because to be blunt just listening on
you know we won't be able to raise the
social media argument in a planning
application so I climate change is tough
and making a tough decision means making
the decision that gets the thing into
the public consultation the easy
decision is to say no but the outcome I
absolutely fear the outcome will be that
in 12 or 18 months time we'll all be sat
around this room thinking well how did
it get planning permission then so
members be just think long and hard
about what you're trying to achieve um I
I cannot support the amendment I
absolutely firmly support our office
that getting this into public
consultation is absolutely the best way
to ensure that this site
um MO is is
safeguarded and um I will probably just
end
there thank you councelor fton and now
finally councelor Pella and then we'll
put the amendment to the vote thank you
um thank you chair um well where do I
start so first of all it's not our int
ention to remove it from the site
allocation plan It's Our intention to
actually have it as a safeguarded site
in the same way that for example other
sites have been safeguarded because they
were important uh for for infrastructure
or for employment so we are asking the
question to the public everyone will
have their say but our question will be
whether this site should be safeguarded
the landowner are likely to object to a
safeguarding policy but let them
demonstrate that a public examination
that the destruction of this natural
asset satisfies the requirements of
national and local planning
policy and regarding the 300 houses
where we are going toe to put them where
in just in the last in in the last week
I had application for 28 houses which
are not uh which were not part of the of
the core strategy in my world we are
expecting 66 uh more uh houses as well
and that's already nearly 100 houses so
we you know these houses are being um
put forward anyway and um uh councelor
Mark Caril um comment about the
southwestern relief Road uh surely uh if
uh any uh spare Road capacity should be
allocated to the uh Garden Village you
know what happens to these up to 300
houses on the on this area how how we're
going to cope with that what where is
the spare capacity going uh so maybe
that's something that Mr carford can can
um also explain um so I uh you know the
fact that we are actually asking uh or
that this Administration is asking
whether uh Woodlands should be destroyed
really shows that uh they are not
committed to The Climate
emergency um and to The Climate
catastrophe that is is you know is
encompassing this planet um Woodlands
play an a fundamental role uh they
improve you know they they they improve
water quality they reduce um noise they
improve um air quality so they they lock
in carbon uh they are important for the
mental and physical and social
well-being of communities so I urge you
to vote for this amendment to safeguard
Safeguard the site in the site
allocation plan so that we can have our
public consultation and I will like the
vote to be recorded chair thank
you thank you councilor pela so that
concludes the debate on the amendment I
shall now ask uh David buckin to conduct
a role and you're voting either for the
amendment against the amendment or
abstaining over to you David CH chairman
can I just before the vote CC P asked
for this to be a formally recorded vote
is there a second or four I know we we
we're conducting all votes as if they're
recorded but can could you uh is a
second for the motion to formally record
this is a recorded I I will second
that okay so chairman are you content
with
that yes David I am thank you very much
um very similar process to before but we
will be formally recording this in the
minutes of the meeting of of how every
councils are voting so if you could
please repeat when I call your name
whether you're for against against or
abstaining for the motion which has been
the sorry the amendment that has been
put uh chairman of the council councelor
Dixon councelor Dixon against thank you
councelor fitter councelor fitter
abstain councelor Adam councel Adam for
the amendment you counc ok councelor
ulok for the amendment thank you
councelor
Barker councelor Barker against the
amendment thank you councel bromage
Council bromage against the
amendment you councel Carill councilor
Cargill against the amendment thank you
councelor cleave councelor cleave for
the
amendment thank you councelor Crump
councelor Crump against the amendment
thank you councelor Curtis councelor
Curtis for the amendment thank you
councelor
Eden councelor Eden
four thank you councelor Fielding
councelor Fielding
against thank you councelor Fleming
councelor Fleming
against thank you councelor
FK councelor FK for the amendment thank
you councelor Foreman councelor foran
against the
amendment thank you councel Ian fragle
councelor Ian fragle for the
amendment thank you councelor Jenny
franley councelor Jenny franley for the
amendment thank you counc Jackie Harris
can you hear me now
Jackie coun Harris are you able to
verbally
respond I'll come back to councelor
Harris in just one minute chairman
councelor Trevor Harvey councelor Harvey
against councelor to hener sarapin
councelor hener sarapin for the
amendment councelor Jefferson councelor
Jefferson against the
amendment thank you councelor Jennings
councelor Jennings
against thank you councelor
juned councelor juned for the
amendment thank you councelor demny
Kendall is absent councelor
Kettle councelor Kettle against the
amendment thank you councel Mills
councilor Ms against thank you Council
odonnell Council odonnell against the
amendment thank you councelor parry
councelor Parry against the amendment
thank you councelor pton councelor pton
against the amendment thank you councel
pagella councelor pela for the amendment
thank you councel
Richards councelor Richards
against thank you councelor Riley
councilor VY for the
amendment thank you councelor rock
councelor rock for the
amendment thank you uh councelor
wolf councilor wolf for the
amendment thank you uh councelor shenton
councelor shenton against the
amendment thank you councel Wally
hoggins councelor Wally hoggins against
the
amendment we are still trying to contact
councilor Harry on the phone can
hopefully we can bear with us thank you
thank you chairman Council Harris has
responded in
chat thank you Council bom I I can see
counc bomis has responded in the chat we
need that verbally um we need to hear
that ver I'm sorry C
bage
we're still trying to establish contact
with councelor Harris she's on the phone
but we've also got her laptop playing in
the background
coun Harris are you there
now can you ask David can you ask her
councelor haris are you
there chairman I I can't hear C can they
hear me
yes we can hear you now
councelor yes can you hear me yes yes we
can hear you
Jackie yeah um after all the whoar I
went with through with glh you don't see
this site as any different we should
follow the process and I'm against thank
you councelor Harris thank
you so chairman there were 14 votes in
favor of the amendment 20 against with
one abstention and therefore the
amendment is
lost thank you David now it's uh 3 and
A4 hours since uh this meeting started I
know that there is another amendment to
be put in respect of the site
allocations plan but before we can do
that we do need to take a vote as to
whether this Council
continues my proposal is that uh we
continue for another 45 minutes till 6
o' and at that point if we are still in
meeting we'll need to take another vote
to continue or to end the meeting
so my proposal is that we continue for
another 45 minutes
um can I see anybody in in chat who
would object to that continuation
please chairman I think that's consensus
to
continue I I think everybody wishes to
continue as I said I know that we have
another amendment coming to us so on
that basis I shall ask for councelor
Peter hen sarapin toh to speak thank
you uh thank you chair ton yeah John for
this as well uh can I just remind people
these counselors in this uh
meeting that we are the lowest area of
trees in this country in Europe and the
last thing we should be doing is cutting
any trees down and I think before any
planning or been made this should be
taken more into consideration where we
going to put
houses um if you want if you can read my
short statement there or would you like
me to read it
out if you could read it out please p
okay right I would look like to put
forward an amendment to The Reserve site
application
plan for Mur green land between the
a435 and far more Lane
Reddit site map a map B and map C be
taken out of the reserve sites of the
site maaor allocation plan for the
following reasons stated that building
on this
land would be cutting down a large
number of mature trees disturbing
Wildlife such as
deer and would result in the merging of
settlements of different
authorities it has been recommended at
ADR inquiries that this land be retained
as screening between reddish and maple
green and as this Council adopted the
climate change this would go against it
I'm sure that better alternative sites
could be found in and around Mur green
so I asked the council to take out
Reserve sides from this allocation plan
thank
you
thank you councilor hin thank you uh is
that uh Amendment
seconded yes it
is uh has there a counselor who's going
to second that one ah councelor Eden has
indicated in chat you'd like to speak to
that councelor
Eden uh only to confirm as neighboring
Ward member and former Studley parish
council member uh the segregation
between that area and redit is
long desired to be maintained so I will
gladly second
this thank you councelor Eden um I would
like to ask uh John careford if he'd
like to make a comment on this proposed
amendment thank you
John thank you chairman um yes
again with with Ron Val it's very
similar it's an it's an opportunity to
uh put this in the consultation and seek
comments on on the on the idea on the
concept um again this is an area of of
Plantation um I think it might be worth
just um outlining the context for this
uh it's actually three three small sites
total of 55 homes is being proposed
chairman um there would be some knock on
consequences from removing these three
sites from the site allocations plan
they are proposed as Reserve sites um
they are Al which is policy sap one they
are also proposed uh for release to meet
the needs of Birmingham under policy sap
four so both in terms of the the total
numbers we're looking for Reserve sites
as well as which sites we would look to
release uh there would be
implications from their their removal
from the plan um in terms of the
context um so this is uh non- Green Belt
land uh in up in the map of green it
sits between the 435 and the boundary
with redit um the the adjacent land to
the West which is in redich uh was is
allocated in the regish local plan for
Housing
Development um and as a council we did
object to that
allocation however the local reddish
local plan has been adopted on the basis
of that allocation being there and that
site is coming forward due course for
it's Circa 200 homes in light of that
context that change
context we've taken the view as to what
is uh the best outcome here is it
retention of some private Woodlands now
there a footpath you can walk a Tac
footpath you can walk through but the
woodlands themselves are private um
again there's no planning restriction on
the felling of trees although it would
require a forry commission license as I
understand it um but what is better is
it the retention of private Woodlands or
by enabling uh say 55 homes to come
forward as part of a more comprehensive
development you would see new publicly
accessible open space space some
Landscaping uh buffers um that the the
residents could use M of green and OB
the new could use that open space as
part of immunity for the village so
again it's it's a balance of where where
judgment goes uh your advice officers is
to consult on that to see if that is uh
indeed the right balance so that's the
the context hope that's helpful Jim
thank
you thank you
John right we've had a proposal an
amendment proposed we've had it seconded
and now open the debate and you can
indicate in chat please if you wish to
speak to this
amendment
Council AB
bromich yeah it seems to be following a
little bit of a trend here at the moment
how we're object putting amendments to
try and remove sites from this the
allocation
plan I think what we have to understand
as counselors is we don't have this site
allocation plan in the correct time it
can compromise the course
strategy the problem we have about
Woodland open space Countryside
Etc that is something we should be
dealing with when we are looking at our
planning policy in general and when we
Grant applications to what we should be
doing this is not about granting
applications this is about making sure
that we have a site allocation plan to
ensure that our local housing plan is
legally sound now
we as I mentioned earlier have to be
very careful because with central
government trying to relax planning
regulations and trying to make in favor
developers that if we don't have
watertight plans in place they will
challenge they will turn around and test
everything as they have been doing since
we adopted the core
strategy we none of us want to see
excessive development in our areas
none of us like that thought and as
somebody who has seen part of the place
where he grew up and then what was meant
to be an air of restraint built on of
the thing and has had an impact despite
what was said by people at planning
committee at the time and I'm sure
councils at shipston in their area
restraint will probably mention the same
things or be thinking the same things
now we are going to have to at the
moment turn around the to say National
planning policy framework rips against a
climate
change however going forward what we
should be looking to do is probably to
amend our planning policies to try and
then rectify the indiscretions that are
currently in the planning policies and
hopefully make them legally sound enough
so they can't be challenged under
National planning policy framework I
think we've got to be very careful keep
saying don't want this site we don't
want this site we don't want this site
because eventually we run out of options
and then we become subject to the
developers whims and when these things
go to appeal which invariably a do when
they put the applications in we're
liable to lose them I went through a
very difficult process on my own Ward
trying to prevent a development of 300
odd house on stove Valley I know how
hard was to get a legally sound argument
not to get planning permission on that
we got away with it at that point but we
are not going to keep getting away with
it big developers will challenge if we
don't turn around and give them reason
not to challenge going forward yes we do
need to look at our planning policy but
now is not the time to be discussing
that planning
policy thank you councelor romich
councelor Peller
yes I I just I I'm very disappointed
that these sites are included in the
site allocation plan uh as as as for uh
allocated for uh development or as a
reserve site for Housing Development and
I just want to ask the question and I
don't know whether this is a question
for the council or for the officers but
why were not these sides these wooded
site these important Wildlife sites
protected in the site allocation plan
uh designated safeguarded in the site
allocation plan especially after the
climate emergency motion was declared I
I do not understand that and um you know
uh I would like an answer because you
know including them uh you are asking
the question whether this should be
developed you are asking the question
whether we should clear trees and
Woodlands um you know in in the era of
of you know wildlife Extinction in the
Hera of climate crisis and I just want
to why were these sites not seg Garden
in the same way that employment site was
guard in the same way the a46 road is
been safeguarded for infrastructure
thank you thank you councelor perella uh
councelor
Curtis thank you chair yes I'd just like
to reiterate um Council perella's point
and this was something I did ra raise
with officers previously it seems to be
extraordinary that the fact that these
are wooded sites does not appear to have
been taken into
account it's and in this time of climate
change and so forth that does seem to be
an extraordinary emission and again to
reiterate the point I made earlier
rather than uh the fact that the other
sites haven't been identified doesn't
seem to me to be a valid reason for not
safeguarding these two sites thank you
thank you councelor Curtis uh hopefully
nobody else wishes to repeat something
that somebody else has already said um
so I'll now ask councelor pton to speak
on this one and then finally we'll go
back to councelor hen H seraphin in
order to wrap up on this one Amendment
thank
you thank you chairman um I'll start by
trying to pick up the climate change
point this Council um quite rightly in
my opinion declared a climate
emergency and since that day I have told
any member of this Authority who cares
to listen that our current core strategy
is not fit for purpose in achieving our
climate change objetives the reason for
that is that the core strategy was
written beforehand and declaring a
climate emergency didn't invalidate the
core strategy the way we the way we get
to a set of policies that give life to
our determined aim around climate change
is a new South warshire plan and members
will know that I have already advised
that work on that will start in November
so we are where we
are okay just to just to just to cut
that out there was no opportunity just
to change T like that because the core
strategy is a legal document and uh
would be open to challenge if we tried
to do it that way as far as this site is
concerned again just let's just trust
the process we have to recognize reality
that a neighboring Authority allocated
land next door for 200 homes those homes
are going to be built whether we like it
or not they're going to be built so our
officers are looking at what is the best
possible
outcome um one outcome is the retention
of the trees as they are uh the officers
feel that it is worth testing an
alternate um strategy that allows for
the establishment of uh 55 homes and an
open space an open space that maintains
the separation from apple green an open
space that of itself will have
biodiversity
upsides again um if we want to find a
way of preserving the best outcome for
the site um think about the outcome the
outcome is best achieved by getting this
site through a robust focused open
public consultation and if that
consultation comes back um and says that
you know that 55 homes in public open
space is the right answer then we'll
have tested it um just to say we just
take it out because we don't like it
again the landowner can seek the
forestry commission permission to do to
to take the trees down and bring the
site forward so again I would say that
you know we just need to trust the
process here um this is slightly
different because of the the you know
what's happening over the Border but I
can't support the amendment I understand
the sentiments but again it's about
trying to achieve the best outcome thank
you thank you councelor pton now call on
councelor hener serin to uh make the
final word before we go to the vote on
this amendment okay thank you chair well
I'm sorry I disagree with you councelor
pton it's not just about sentiments it's
about trees and
Wildlife and sucking up carbon because
if those trees are removed never mind
Open Spaces it's the trees we need to
protect especially near a main
road and if you look at what actually
the NHS recommend that we do not build
new houses near main roads nor schools
and no Care Homes so what we're trying
to do and what the people in Mur are
trying to do is to keep that
distinctiveness as a village away from
the sprawl of Reddit and even if Reddit
build on their half we'll still have a
screen of
trees okay that's all I got to say thank
you thank you councelor henin right
we'll now go to the votes I would ask Mr
butland if you could take the roll call
please thank you chairman so so Regular
Pack dra here so if when I call your
name if you could please uh respond as
to whether you are voting for against or
abstaining for the amendment that's been
put so um counc
Dixon councelor Dixon against thank you
councelor fitter councelor fitter
against thank you councelor Adam
councelor Adam for thank you councelor
ok councelor ok for thank you councelor
Barker councelor Barker
against thank you councel bromage
councelor bromage against thank you
councel Carill councelor Cargill against
thank you councelor cleave councelor
cleave for thank you councelor Crump
councelor Crump against thank you
councelor Curtis councelor Curtis for
thank you councel
Eden councelor Eden
for thank you councel Fielding councelor
Fielding against thank you councelor
Fleming councelor Fleming against thank
you councelor ftic councelor foic for
thank you councelor Foreman councelor
Foreman against thank you councelor Ian
fredley councelor Ian fragle for thank
you councelor Jenny fragle councelor
Jenny franley four thank you councelor
Jackie
Harris C Jackie Harris you
there
we'll come back to check we'll call
councelor Harris towards the end please
David thank you councelor Trevor Harvey
councelor Harvey
against councel hener
sarapin councelor hener sarapin
for councelor Jefferson councelor
Jefferson against thank you councelor
Jennings councelor Jennings against
thank you councelor juned councelor
juned
for thank you councelor Kendall abson
councel
Kettle councel Kettle against thank you
councel Mills councelor Mills against
thank you councel odonnell councelor
odonnell
against thank you councelor parry
councelor Parry against thank you
councel
pton councelor pton against the
amendment thank you councel Pella
councelor Pella for the amendment thank
you councelor Richards councelor
Richards against thank you councelor
Riley councelor Riley for the amendment
thank you councelor rock councelor rock
for the amendment thank you councel Rolf
councelor Rolf for the
amendment
shenton that wasn't me
barking councelor shenton
against thank you uh councel Wally
hoggins councelor Wally hoggins
against thank you is councelor Harris
there
now you're on now Jackie okay uh we've
got councelor Harris on the phone I
think thank you councelor Jackie Harris
are you for against or abstaining for
the
amendment hello Jeffy Harris we can just
hear you is that for or against the
amendment
please
I not yes har would you like to give
your vote
please I don't know what you mean I'm
waiting for David should call my name
Harris if you just want to say for or
against or abstain
please all right okay well I have to
answer when he spoke right well I'm
against then please thank you counc
Harris the amendment is lost thank
you
thank you
David I've lost I've lost control of my
mic now there it
is right uh the two amendments which
we've had have both been lost we now
back to the original four which were
proposed uh and uh
seconded uh does anybody wish to ah
Council Parry I saw you in the chat a
long time ago saying that you wanted uh
to speak but not to the amendment is
this about the uh the four uh
recommendations as per page
112 uh thank you chairman yes I I won't
speak quite as long because I think most
of the points have already been made but
I just wanted to use the opportunity to
um thank those residents from meon Vil
for actually taking the time and trouble
to write to me and drawing my attention
to their concerns which I understand um
and to actually say I've I've been
involved with this site for over seven
years um from sort of a planning and a
policy uh stage so I'm particularly
familiar with it and obviously the key
issue that we have here is that we just
can't fight National planning policy
which is dictated us um by government
and also the planning inspectorate so
what we have to do is actually work with
it rather than against it which is
obviously what uh myself and my
colleagues have have been doing and
because of it's Brown field status you
know the complex and the process is well
it's it's very it's very complex um um
and I just wanted to reinforce that what
we're trying to do is actually give it
more protection and not less and I think
that at this next public consult uh
consultation stage which will provide us
with the evidence Gathering opportunity
that I know everybody is looking to get
to because what we all want to do is to
give it to get the right weight required
in order to play put houses in the right
place at the right time build the right
houses in the right place whilst also
obviously maximizing and protecting what
Green Space we can for everybody's
enjoyment um it's also interesting to
note that me and Vil not only delivers
both a sense of place with
desirability together with housing
affordability
because actually it has such a much
lower cost in terms of the land because
the Brownfield element to it so it's
it's it's ideal in terms of delivering
more affordable homes which I know
everyone is very keen to to do so if
councilors vote against the site
allocations plan they'll actually be
giving developers a ticket to ride
shotgun all over meon Vil which which
which is what we don't want we want the
right houses in the right place so I'm
actually Keen to propose a recorded vote
on this um because I particularly want
local residents to know which counselors
will be making the right decision in
their best interest for the right
reasons by supporting this proposal in
order to Take Back Control of what
happens to sites and in particular what
happens to me me and Vil that's all
chairman cut short
thank you councelor
parry uh I'll take the speakers that
I've got listed already and then we'll
uh ensure that that proposal is possibly
seconded I see already in the queue that
there are comments there so councelor
Adam next
please thank you chairman um I had a few
points which uh I think have been raised
through the the debate on the the
Amendments but these are specific to the
the general motion as it as it
stands it does appear that what's being
suggested is that it's going out to
consultation uh with no input from the
council that's what seems to be
suggested by this that's clearly not the
case because what's going out for
consultation is a suggestion from
offices it's not a blank consultation
what that feeds into is the point that's
been of concern to my local parishes in
that they have not been able to feed
into that prior to it being formulated
for more public
consultation what I feel and what they
feel
similarly is that input from these
valuable Lo Community leaders at an
earlier stage could have informed this
before we got to the stage that went out
to public and made the process more uh
streamlined better and and avoided some
of the issues that have clearly caused
concern what this also relates to is
that some of the sites whether they are
being proposed um for development or not
in any any way um have been shown to be
totally unsuitable around long
itchington for instance there are sites
which are shown to be wholly or or
related to flood um zones which would be
completely inappropriate for any type of
development at any point in the future
these should be excluded at the outset
and the fact that they are um
highlighted on the plan as possible
sites for any future um site allocation
plan this one included uh is U of great
concern especially considering the
issues that this local community has had
with flooding due to recent
development I'd also like to point out
that you know when concerning the time
scale this is the second um derivation
of a site allocation plan that has been
produced by this Council uh in recent
years this is because of the
miscommunication and Chang of tack
that's come through coordinating the
approach to this plan with the county
with the County Council specifically in
relation to exclusion Zone around sou
college now this extension uh to the
time scale and the massive extension in
cost to the taxpayer has caused Great
concern to
uh developers and potential uh
beneficiaries of well thought out plan
in the district and this has really
impacted on this so I think that needs
to be highlighted that when we're
talking about extending the time scale
and extending the cost that this has
already happened because of the way in
which this has been managed to
[Music]
date I think that's all I've got to say
but uh I think that that really does
touch on on the issues that have been
raised so far and how they appli to the
whole site allocation plan thank you
very
much thank you councelor Adam councelor
juned uh yes can I agree with councelor
Adam there seems to be grave mistrust uh
amongst members of the public about um
planning uh and uh uh the even amongst
counselors as well uh
particularly there does seem to have
been uh I know that this is a
consultation but it would have been
better to have had more um discussion
amongst coun beforehand now I want to
safe I wanted to safeguard these two
Woodland sites that been in no doubt
about that that I will defend Woodland s
the amendments were defeated so what I
want to do now and again I want to make
this absolutely
clear I am not giving in at all I want
to fight for better conditions for my
residents for my district by presenting
evidence through the
consultation I want to make sure that
the data is put in that the the core
strategy that we start building towards
the core strategy by telling people and
telling any inspector when it gets to
that stage just how important Woodlands
are how important mental health and
well-being
are say I will not I do understand that
there is grave Mis
mistrust but one of the things later on
you've got a notice of motion which will
not be discussed but in that I am
seeking local Green Space designation
through the next uh core strategy this
is how much I believe in making sure
that we fight I have CL High climate
change expectations I will make sure
that I put evidence into the
consultation to to uh support Woodlands
climate change and and and fighting for
my residents thank
you
thank you councelor juned councelor
bromich yeah I think first of all I
think we have to realize that we are
where we are at the moment because
actually our course strategy when it was
originally done and passed that was not
compatible with where we are now on some
of the decisions in the past 12 months
we've taken as a
council that very same course strategy I
remember arguing certainly against quite
a few
sites on grounds of environmental impact
Etc on it
unfortunately that's not taken account
in the National planning policy
framework I AC what I Echo what
councilor junior is say that for our
next course strategy we do need to have
a better environmentally based one and I
have been assured already in discussions
I have had already with people involved
with that that that is their aims and
Targets on that part so hopefully it
will come true the issue we have now is
we can't undo the existing core strategy
therefore when it comes to site
allocation plan we have to base it on
what that core strategy was back in
2016 that makes it very very awkward to
turnar around and say we want to reject
things on environmental grounds because
as I've mentioned already developers
will simply go to appeal and inspector
will look there they will go through
National planning policy framework they
will throw out say any defense the
council have until such a Time central
government alter National planning
policy
framework My Grave concern is unless we
have this understanding and go through
this process now Consulting with what we
have there what we will end up with is
our core strategy as it stands fors and
we go back to the developer freefor all
that will be far far more damaging it
will mean those Woodlands that are
seeking to be protected or partly
protected will go because we won't have
a legal leg to stand on because the
developers will argue their case
especially with the back of the central
government it means also that we have to
be realistic now that we've been dealt a
bad hand in the past but let's get it
right for the future so let's start
thinking not about this so much we know
this is going to have a Major Impact but
how we make the future better it means
our next Council meetings we look at
housing policies we look at how we're
going to do our next course strategy we
start engaging and writing things and
making them legally sound so this can
never happen again that's something we
can't undo now but we can stop in the
future if we so determined
to thank you councilor bramich uh
councelor Carill you've indicated in
chat that you would happy to Second the
name Dev vote I'll also invite you to
speak to that as well if you wish thank
you very much indeed uh I do I think
finally the message is starting to get
across we are passionate about our
district we want to protect it the whole
point of the consultation the public
consultation is to be able to express
our view so yes finally I think the
message is getting across and thank you
very much
indeed uh would you like to uh formly
second that name vote please Council C I
will formally second the named vote for
the proposal thank you very much
chairman you uh councelor fo
please thank you chair yeah just very
quickly times is obviously running on
I'll be voting in favor of this um this
proposal um me on Veil side I suppose
but that's actually that's gone that's
been lost that Amendment um but for the
sake of all the other sites it is a
sound plan and it needs to go go forward
so I'll be voting for it but um holding
my nose I suppose on the mean Veil part
of
it thank you Council of H I'll know ask
councelor Jefferson as a seconder to the
proposal and then finally councelor pton
to wrap up councelor
Jefferson thank you chair all I really
want to say is I think uh given the
comments I've heard it is absolutely
vital that we agree to this so I'm fully
in
support thank you councel Jefferson
councilor pton please thank you chair uh
uh I I too am fully in support of we
must get this uh plan out to public
consultation um I think I'm just going
to have to take issue with a couple of
things right said at the very end by uh
by a number of members um first of all
um this has not been dropped on
everybody um when this when this went
before overview and scrutiny uh and I'm
not going to have criticism of our
officers who've had a long engagement
process with members with parish and
town councils so uh if if members
haven't been paying attention then I'm
have to say uh there have been
opportunities and I have to say that I
am really disappointed that I get
substantive and game-changing motions
brought with no opportunity I had a
conversation with the lead the
opposition group leader uh last week
inviting councelor hen cherin to come
and talk to me uh we do need to discuss
these things to turn around and bring
these things forward right at the death
um is just game playing and I am not
also going to let it stand that there is
distrust about public consultation for
this local Authority in my opinion that
is sown solely by the opposition group
they're the only ones talking about
distrust in public consultation and I'm
not going to have our
officers criticized when our public
consultations have a reputation for
being open and robust uh and uh I think
I now probably need to end because I
think we should get to the vote before
teams Cuts us all off thank
you thank you councilor pton right I now
call on Mr Buckland to take the role the
uh four recommendations as per
112 uh thank you
David thank you chairman um can I just
confirm chairman it was a suggestion
from councilor Parry that this be a
recorded vote I believe there was some
seconders for that proposal it was
indeed in the chat so would you like me
to conduct this as a recorded vote then
chairman yes please thank you chairman
um again if you could please indicate
whether you're voting for against or
abstaining for the recommendations as
laid out on page 112 of the agenda uh
chairman of council councelor Dixon
councelor Dixon four thank you um
councelor fitter councelor fitter
abstain thank you councelor Adam councel
Adam
Paul thank you councel
oock councelor oock four thank you
councelor Barker councelor Barker for
thank you councelor bromage councelor
bromage for thank you councelor Cargill
councel Cargill for thank you councelor
cleave councelor cleave
abstain thank you councelor Crump
councelor Crump for thank you councelor
Curtis councelor Curtis for thank you
councelor
Eden councelor Eden for thank you
councelor Fielding councelor Fielding
for thank you councelor Fleming
councelor Fleming for thank you
councelor FK councelor FK for thank you
councelor Foreman councelor Foreman for
thank you councelor Ian fredley
councelor Ian fredley for thank you
councelor Jenny fredley councelor Jenny
fredley for thank you I will try
councelor Harris although indicated in
chat she wouldn't be able to respond
councelor
Harris okay councelor Harvey councelor
Harvey four thank you councelor hen s
councel hen serin for thank you coun
Jefferson councelor Jefferson
for councelor Jennings councelor
Jennings
Paul thank you uh councelor juned
councelor juned four thank you councel
Kendall is absent councelor
Kettle councelor k for thank you councel
Mills councel Mills for thank you
O'Donnell counc penan o Donnell Council
o Donnell four thank you councelor parry
councelor Parry for thank you councelor
pton councelor pton for thank you
councelor Pella councelor Pella
abstain thank you councelor
Richards councelor Richards
for thank you uh councelor Ry councelor
Riley
abstain thank you uh councelor rock
councelor rock for thank you councelor
Rolf councelor Rolf four thank you
councelor shenton councelor shenton four
thank you and councelor Wally hoggins
councelor Wally hoggins
four thank you um chairman that was 30
votes for four exensions just just to
know councelor Harris has indicated her
support but I can't count her vote in
this vote thank you thank you David So
moving on with a few minutes before 6
o'cl um item 11 on the agenda notice of
motion class Q technical guidance and I
invite councelor reallyy hoggins as
Community portfolio holder to introduce
this item which may be a brief one uh
thank you
counselor yes keeping this as brief as
possible there um consideration was
given to report in response to a motion
in the names of councils Pella and rock
in respect of Cl Q technical guidance as
presented at the cabinet meeting on the
27th of July
2020 um the report concluded that in
light of existing guidance regarding the
class Q Pro process and the drawbacks
outlining section three of the agenda
report it was considered unnecessary to
produce further guidance on this
particular area of the planning system
so it is recommended to C to council
therefore that the class Q technical
guidance um is is not produced and the
council continued to refer to existing
National legislation and Technical
guidance and that the notice of motion
be
rejected further support for this or
further backup of this is that um at
appeals when things go to appeal uh we
win over two-thirds of the cases which
means that we are very high on the list
of knowing precisely what we are doing
but we've also care of and Parry uh
We've also uh stated that we do need to
have um some upto-date training on um
class cute technical guidance for all
for all members and I thank an Parry for
uh making that
suggestion thank you councilor Wy
hoggins uh can I see a second for this
in the chat
please I've already done it
John
Fielding I can't see it in the chat but
on the basis that everybody heard uh
Council of Fielding uh we'll take that
as a a seconding uh the proposal does
anybody wish to speak or shall we go
straight to the vote on this
one chairman councilor Pella has
indicated
thank you David uh councilor
perella yes I I'll be brief I I still
think that it would be very useful to
have technical guidance for all people
concerned from members to Parish Council
and actually the technical guidance will
compl um a a program of training on on
class q and other permitted development
so um you know to understand the process
um for example the timing you know that
that this class Q applications have a
very limited amount of time so that
could be uh flesh out in a technical
guidance and so on so I just want to say
that um I will vote against this
recommendation so to come back to
counselor Pella that um that um any my
it is my understanding that any
councilors be from Parish or District or
County can can join our training
sessions on the class Q guidance when
that comes through and all will be
entirely welcome to do so thank you
thank coun W hoggins uh councelor pton
wishes to
speak thank you chairman I think you pay
your money you take your choice uh we
either do work on things like class Q
technical guidance or we crack on with a
new South wara plan and keep climate
change at the heart of everything we do
we can't do everything thank
you thank you councelor
pton uh councelor
shenton thank you chairman uh um just a
very quick one to say that I was one of
the supporters originally to this been
referred to officers um but that the
thought of spending time on money on
producing a guide that wouldn't offer
any more clarity than existing National
legislation in my opinion is NE required
or desirable at this stage to quote from
the report produced by the officer any
publication from the council could
potentially divert from this or
mislead I therefore say that we should
move to a vote in
favor thank you thank you councilor
shenton nobody else showing in the chat
I think we can therefore put the
proposal that's been proposed and
seconded to the vote uh Co David if
you'd like to take a roll call please
thank you chairman we're voting now on
the recommendations on page 113 of the
agenda um councelor Dixon chairman of
council
counc Dixon for against
abstaining councelor Dixon four thank
you councelor fitter councelor fitter
four thank you councelor Adam councel
Adam
against thank you councel
ok councelor ok against thank you
councel Barker councel Barker four thank
you councel bromage councilor promit for
thank you councel Carill councelor
Cargill for thank you councelor cleave
councelor cleave
against thank you councelor Crump
for thank you councelor Curtis councelor
Curtis
against thank you councelor
Eden councelor Eden
against thank you councelor Fielding
councelor Fielding for thank you
councelor Fleming councelor Fleming
for thank you councelor FK councelor FK
for thank you councelor Foreman
councelor Foreman for thank you
councelor Ian fredley councelor Ian
fredley against thank you councelor
Jenny fredley councelor Jenny fely
against thank you councelor
Harris okay councelor Harvey councelor
Harvey for thank you councelor hen serin
councelor Hena sarapin against
councelor Jefferson councelor Jefferson
for thank you councelor Jennings
councelor Jennings for thank you
J councelor juned against thank you
councelor
K Chris councelor Chris
kle councelor Kettle for thank you
councelor Mills counc Mills for thank
you counc odonnell councelor Donald for
thank you councelor parry councelor
Parry for thank you councel pton
councelor pton for thank you councelor
Pella councelor Pella against thank you
councelor Richards councelor Richards
for thank you councel
Riley coun Riley against thank you counc
rock councelor rock
against thank you councel wolf councelor
wolf against thank you councelor shenton
councelor shenton for thank you and
councelor Wally hoggins councilor Wally
hoggins
for thank you chairman that was carried
thank you uh thank you
David that has brought us to a neat
point in the in the meeting and this is
now just a moment past 6 o'cl um we have
councelor questions of which obviously
they've been asked and uh the answers
have been provided obviously there is
the opportunity to supplementary if we
continue then there's questions to the
leader and then there's the notice of
motion I uh am minded to think that we
ought to perhaps either be adjourning
the council meeting and reconvening at a
future date to carry on
alternatively my absolute maximum would
probably be another 30 minutes to get
everything done what the members think
please indicate in the
chat
I think we shall press on for another 30
minutes to 6:30 and then if we've not
done we shall finish
so perhaps we should just take any
supplementary questions if there are any
and just crack through those to get
to suggestion that we should go straight
to the supplementary questions if there
are there any supplementary questions at
all in respect of those Mr chairman Mr
chairman could I raise another Point
I've suggested in chat that because of
the time constraints and we've got votes
can we do supplementaries by
email I would be perfectly happy with
that I would be perfectly happy with
that response and to proceed on the
basis that questions have been asked the
answers have been provided supp suppies
are available but I'd be perfectly happy
for supplementaries to be put by email
and circulated to all
members
chairman chairman yes uh as a leader I'm
quite happy people want to email me
questions and I'll
respond thank you councelor
Jefferson on that basis we'll move
through the Council of questions and
questions to the leader again to Tony by
email to everybody replies to
everybody on that basis I think we can
perhaps move to the notice of motion
item
14 uh councelor Richards to speak
please councelor Richards um uh chairman
I was indicating I wish to speak to a
conversation that had happened
previously um so not on this item it
we've passed it now so I will
refrain thank you very much Council
[Music]
Richards right councelor juned happy
with it okay so we'll move through to uh
item 14 on the agenda notices motion
motion is to be proposed by councelor
junid councelor
junid uh thank you in in light of the T
of the of the time um that uh I believe
that it would be best for this to go to
Cabinet but with an officer's report I
really do feel uh quite strongly about
the matter but I think it is one that uh
councelor councilors will be able to
make a judgment on once they see an
officer report thank you thank you
councelor juned uh the uh motion to be
seconded by councilor perel I
believe yes I'll second the motion and I
also agree with um councelor juned uh
that um we would have a officer report
that goes to cabinet with an officer
report thank you councelor pela thank
you now on the basis that the uh notice
of motion has been proposed and seconded
uh in accordance with Council procedural
rules uh the report of that motion once
proposed statement will be referred to
cabinet for consideration and Report
without further debate so on the basis
that questions are indeed taken by email
I will now ask is there any urgent
business uh
butland chairman there's no edge of
business thank you thank you David on
that basis I close the meeting thank you
okay and thank you to
everybody